Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nummer 033 zu Gast haben wir heute Sascha Lobo. Guten Tag.
Hallo.
Und wir wollen uns heute mal wieder ein bisschen über Politik unterhalten. Und insbesondere geht es um ein Phänomen, das Fefe mal politische Hohlphrasen genannt hat.
Also ich reg mich da immer wieder darüber auf. Jetzt machen wir eine Sendung und da zerlegen wir oder verbrennen wir diese Hohlphrase mal alle. So ein paar Beispiele bringen. Meine Lieblings-Hohlphrase ist, wir haben ein Maßnahmenpaket beschlossen.
Oder ein Maßnahmenbündel.
Ein umfassendes Maßnahmenpaket, wenn es sich um wirklich großes Problem handelt oder ein Bündel von Maßnahmen. Eine andere beliebte Hohlphrase ist, wir haben ein Gesetz auf den Weg gebracht. Ja, weil das klingt ja schön. Wir haben getan, was wir konnten jetzt ist aus unseren Händen. Und wenn es jetzt vor den Baum fährt, ist nicht unsere Schuld, wir haben es ja nur gestartet. Also diese Implikationen sind es, die mir auf den Nerv geben.
Also sozusagen so die Werner von Braun-Variante von Gesetzes.
Genau. Das ist die Implikation. Aber es ist natürlich, im Grunde ist Politik am Ende PR und Framing. Also die Frage ist, wie du es dann so formulierst, dass gleich die Weltsicht der Rezipienten geformt wird, in deinem Sinne. Und dieses Gesetz auf den Weg bringen, ist eine Sache, die das halt exemplarisch macht in meinen Augen. Dann hab ich hier noch, unser Mitgefühl gilt jetzt den Opfern. Das ist so eine Hau-drauf-Phase, wenn die Opposition kommt und sagt, das war aber unsere Schuld, wir hätten verhindern sollen, dass da Häuser gebaut werden, wo jetzt der Fluss ist. Dann heißt es, unser Mitgefühl gilt jetzt den Opfern, oder Flugzeug ist abgestürzt, hätte es dann nicht besser regulieren gehen müssen. Nein, unser Mitgefühl gilt jetzt den Opfern. Also diese Art von Phrasen, die nerven mich schon lange.
Dabei, unser Mitgefühl gilt den Opfern, ist ja noch mal doppelt dubios. Weil dir impliziert, dass es, ja, ist halt so.
Als wenn euer Mitgefühl nicht den Opfern gilt.
Genau, als wenn die anderen sozusagen fiese, unemotionale, ja.
Ich hab da gleich am Anfang schon nicht ganz einen Kontrapunkt, aber ich sehe das so ein bisschen anders an vielen Punkten. Auch wenn mich Phrasen wahnsinnig nerven, glaube ich, dass viele von denen vergleichsweise gedankenlos einfach so gedroppt werden, auch so ritualisiert und dass da in zwar vorhandenen, aber deutlich seltenen Fällen, als du das gerade vermutest, so ein großer Masterplan dahinter ist, um jetzt wirklich alles irgendwie wegzuschieben oder zu vertuschen. Also ich glaube, dass Phrasen tatsächlich ein Problem sind, aber viel eher, weil die aus so einer Überzeugung geschehen, die ich seit einiger Zeit in der Politik ausmache, die gibt es bestimmt schon ganz lange. Ich mache sie bloß seit einiger Zeit erst aus. Nämlich die Verantwortungsebenen möglichst zu verwirren oder zu verschieben, jedenfalls von sich wegzuschleudern. Und das Krasse ist, dass wenn man näher rankuckt an dieses politische System, dass das dann häufig sogar stimmt. Dass zwar ein Minister behaupten muss, er habe sein Haus im Griff und er könne da Politik machen, aber faktisch ist seine Handlungsfreiheit ziemlich beschränkt.
Also dieses Phänomen, dass gerade auch viele Ministerien ja eigentlich überall im Wesentlichen von den Beamteten, Staatssekretären und Regierungsdirektoren geflogen werden. Und der Minister, der Parlamentarer Staatssekretär, die sind halt die Typen, die alle vier Jahre wechseln. Die Sprecher.
Im Grunde die Sprecher, die Scheiß, den ihr Haus macht, verkaufen müssen.
Ich denke, wenn man sowas zum dritten oder vierten Mal, so die dritten oder vierten Minister gesehen hat, dann hat man schon so eine gewisse Routine da drin, die glauben zu lassen, dass sie einen Handlungsspielraum haben, den sie eigentlich gar nicht haben.
Auf der einen Seite mag das so sein und es gibt Ministerien, da erzählt man sich zumindest, dass es so ist. Und ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, aus meiner nicht besonders tiefen, aber häufig erlebten Kenntnis von solchen Apparaten, dass es tatsächlich gesteuert wird von Leuten und der Minister eher im Glauben gelassen wird, er hätte da richtig was zu sagen. Tatsächlich würde ich das noch ein bisschen feindifferenzierter sehen, weil es da auch Unterschiede in den Personen gibt. Was man nicht unterschätzen darf, ist ja, dass ein Minister auch einfach Führungspersonal von heute auf morgen rausschmeißen kann, ohne das wirklich begründen zu müssen. Das geht. Das wurde auch schon häufiger gemacht. Ich glaube, dass es ganz so einfach dann am Ende nicht ist und sich auch sehr unterscheidet von Minister zu Minister.
Ja gut, es gab ja so Fälle. Wenn als Demisierer zum Beispiel an ein Investiment kam, hat er ja irgendwie eher auch seine Leute installiert. Aber wiederum als Friedrich da war, war es ja dann eher so, dass halt irgendwie...
Wobei Friedrich ist ja sogar schon als Politikdarsteller schlecht gecastet. Und wenn man dann auch noch diesen großen Fehler macht, ihn tatsächlich als Politiker zu betrachten, dann kann man aus egal welcher Perspektive ja nur in die Verzweiflung stürzen.
Ich glaube, der hätte auch gar keine Leute gehabt, die er da erst installieren kann.
Also, wenn man die Leute, die er halt von den Dorfkirchen auskennt, ja, also...
Vielleicht nutzen wir den Moment, kurz den Moment nutzen, um den ersten Videotipp auszusprechen. Es gibt eine BBC-Serie namens Yes Minister, die genau dieses hervorragend thematisiert, dass es einen dummen Minister gibt, der die ganze Zeit von seinem schlauen Staatssekretär geführt wird. Sehr empfehlenswert, aus den 80ern.
Aber das Spannende ist, dass diese Polit-Phrasen, wo wir vorhin ausgegangen sind, halt ziemlich genau, nicht ein Beleg, aber doch ein Hinweis darauf wären, dass es tatsächlich solche Sachen vorkommen, wo du als Minister so tun musst, als hättest du etwas in der Hand. Aber du kannst das eigentlich mit vollem und reinem Gewissen gar nicht so sagen. Und da musst du sie ein bisschen drumherum schwimmen. Du kannst jetzt nur sagen, wir unternehmen was gegen X, indem wir Y. Aber faktisch hat er weder die Macht, das zu tun, noch kann er das wirklich bis zum Ende durchprügeln, weil dazwischen irgendwie noch zwischen Parlament und Kanzlerin alles mögliche andere stattfindet, bis hin zu irgendwelchen Einflussgruppen. Also muss er, ist er eigentlich sogar gezwungen, systemisch gezwungen dazu, Formulierungen zu finden, die seinem tatsächlichen Machtstatus gerecht werden. Das würde zumindest erklären, warum da so viel diffuses Quatschzeug dabei ist.
Also ich hab immer das Gefühl, dass diese Phrasen auf so gewissen Moden unterliegen. Und ich bin immer so die Vorstellung, da gibt es dann bestimmt so ein Seminar für so die Ministeriumspressesprecher.
Für Führungskräfte.
Und entweder werden ihnen da solche Phrasen vorgeschlagen oder irgendjemand hat die Idee und die anderen machen es dann nach.
Also ich glaube da an die Evolution.
Also die Redenschreiber von solchen Leuten sind ja auch, also ich meine, das ist ja auch nur ein Job wie jeder andere irgendwie in der PR-Wirtschaft. Und dementsprechend sind die ja auch den normalen Mechanismen dieser PR-Wirtschaft unterworfen. Und wenn man sich so anguckt, also versucht man so ein paar Phrasen zu tracken über die Zeit. Und dann sieht man halt eben auch, dass es da immer so Peaks gibt. Also dass halt so bestimmte Formulierungen halt, also Alternativlos zum Beispiel, als wir damit angefangen haben, kam echt oft vor. Also wurde sozusagen sehr, sehr oft verwendet. Und ist jetzt wieder so ein bisschen so, ist jetzt weg, ausgelaufen?
Ich glaube, es ist auch deswegen ausgelaufen, weil das in der Presse schon ziemlich groß besprochen wurde. Also auch in der relevanten Presse, die aus Sicht der Politik relevant ist, die dann in den Pressespiegeln landet. Das Alternativlos jetzt gerade in diesem Euro-Kontext von Merkel, daher kommt es ja ursprünglich, vielleicht nicht die cleverste Formulierung war. Die ist hunderttausendmal aufgespießt worden. Und selbst wenn es da keinen Masterplan und keine zentralen Kurse für Ministeriums-Sprecher gibt oder so, hat natürlich jemand, der da tätig ist, so ein feines Sensorium dafür. Und wenn der merkt, der Begriff Alternativlos ist jetzt das 58. Mal von irgendeinem SZ Streiflicht ausgespießt worden, dann überlegt diese Person vielleicht, ob sie in Zukunft diesen Begriff nicht mehr ganz so einfach aus dem Ärmel schüttelt.
Interessant sind ja die Sachen, wie sie aufkommen. Also wie sozusagen so eine Begriffe in die Welt kommen. Das ist ja eigentlich interessant. Wie sie dann sterben, ist ja eigentlich normal.
Das ist das Spannende. Ich bin ja seit 2007, vielleicht mal als Erklärung meines Hintergrunds, ich bin irgendwie in die Öffentlichkeit eigentlich geraten mit dem Buch Wer nennen das Arbeit 2006. Und weil da digital im Titel vorkam, im Untertitel, war ich dann Internet-Experte. Da kann man noch mal in eigenen Artikel irgendwann zu schreiben vielleicht. Aber da bin ich über diese schiene Arbeit und digital in das Fahrwasser der SPD geraten und war zwar nie Parteimitglied, aber fand schon immer, dass ich irgendwie eher so linksliberal unterwegs bin. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, können wir mit Ihnen sprechen? Und habe da relativ schnell gemerkt, dass ein ungeheurer Bedarf nach Erklärung dort vorhanden ist. Und gerade was das Digitale angeht, war der sehr hoch. Und da bin ich dann halt in allen möglichen Gesprächskreisen ab 2007 gewesen, von Per Steinbrück, Kreativindustrie, Finanzministerium, von Brigitte Zypries damals Justizministerin in ihrem Gesprächskreis, ich glaube auch digital und Internet oder so, von der SPD selbst, also von der Partei. Und in diesen Parteigesprächskreisen, da fangen die am Anfang an, dich so langsam vorzubereiten darauf, dass Politik anders funktioniert, als man es glaubt. Die sagen zum Beispiel, wir können hier ganz lange reden, aber das Brett, was wir bohren müssen, ist viel, viel dicker, als man das so glaubt. Das stimmt. Und es stimmt sogar für Leute in Machtposition. Das heißt, es ist unfassbar viel schwer verleger und nerviger und langsamer, als man auch nur am Entferntesten annimmt. Und dann aber kommt man immer näher ran und dann gibt's so Momente, wo die Funktionsweise von Politik auf einmal offen darlegt. Wo du so wirklich merkst, da geht irgendwie der Minister so ans Telefon, wechselt nur vier oder fünf Worte mit mutmaßlich jemanden vom Ministerium und du spürst in dem Moment, da passiert etwas, was typisch ist für das, wie Politik funktioniert. Und aus solchen Momenten, nicht nur SPD, sondern auch aus anderen Parteien und auch aus anderen Kontexten, aus solchen Momenten hab ich irgendwann bemerkt, wo es sich lohnt zu bohren, damit man versteht, wie das funktioniert. Und um jetzt diesen sehr langen Bogen zu schlagen, zu dem Punkt, es gibt es tatsächlich, dass Minister sich zusammensetzen mit Kommunikationsexperten und gemeinsam überlegen, wie macht man ein PR-Politikprojekt, das von außen aussieht wie ein ganz normales Politikprojekt, ob das jetzt irgendwie die Maut ist oder Netzsperren oder so. Bei den Netzsperren ist es zum Beispiel wahnsinnig wahrscheinlich, dass es so gekommen ist, dass es einfach eine PR-Veranstaltung war, auf die Ursula von der Leyen aufgesprungen ist damals. Ausgelegt übrigens vom BKA-Chef, da ist es ja auch alles hinlänglich bekannt, wie der erst gesagt hat, wir brauchen eine Diskussion und dann springt halt Ursula von der Leyen drauf und sagt, wir machen jetzt eine Diskussion und das da der PR, der vermeintliche PR-Quickwin total nach hinten losgegangen ist und dann aber tatsächlich PR-Agenturen beauftragt worden sind. Wie kann man über das Wording versuchen, das zu retten? Machen wir eine Flucht nach vorne, weichen wir zur Seite aus? Also, dass da dann wirklich strategisch vorgegangen wird.
Aber erst in der Schadensbegrenzung, nicht vorher.
Das weiß ich, das kann ich nicht genau sagen. Also von der Schadensbegrenzung bin ich fast hundertprozentig sicher, weil ich da aus komischen Gründen relativ nah dran war, die ich auch nicht im Detail erklären möchte. Ob das am Anfang schon PR geplant war, bei diesen Netzplanern kann ich nicht sagen. Aber was ich weiß, ist, dass tatsächlich nur ein Teil genauso geplant ist und noch viel mehr funktioniert zum Teil über unbewusste Mechanismen, zum Teil über bewusste, aber nicht strategisch eingesetzte Mechanismen und zum Teil einfach über den totalen dämlichen Zufall. Man sollte nicht glauben, wie oft so ein dämlicher Zufall auch an Orten, wo man es gar nicht glaubt, am Ende entscheidend ist. Da rutscht einem ein Wort raus und daraus wird quasi eine Art politische Lawine.
Ja, das kenn ich. Also wir machen es ja ähnlich und im CCC, dass wir auch versuchen, für uns wichtige Anliegen Begriffe zu finden, die das Potenzial dazu haben und auch den Kontext so griffig zusammenzufassen, dass es zum Schlagwort dafür wird. Und man kann aber häufig eben auch nicht vorhersehen, was es wird. Also es gab ein paar Sachen, die waren halt irgendwie klar, so Zinsozola zum Beispiel ist auch durch Zufall entstanden, aber war in der Zehntelsekunde, wo, wer es als erstes sagte, Erdgeist war das. Ja, ich glaube Erdgeist war das.
Ich hab's recherchiert.
Rausrutschte. In dem Augenblick war klar, ist jetzt der Begriff, aber in anderen Stellen ist es tatsächlich eben durchaus auch mal mehr zufällig.
Das ist übrigens deswegen interessant, weil das in diese hippe Memetik reinreicht. Also wo Begriffe funktionieren, weil sie sich vervielfältigen, weil sie sich fortpflanzen und es ist deswegen auch interessant, weil ich glaube, dass die Macht dieser Begriffe in der Politik viel größer ist, als man sich von außen das so vorstellt. Dass also bestimmte Begriffe und bestimmte Wendungen, das sind ja nicht nur einzelne Worte, sondern es sind so Halbsätze, die irgendwelche Zusammenhänge erklären, dass die eine richtige Karriere machen und hinterher sogar Leute unter Druck setzen, da eine Politik für zu entwickeln. Und das finde ich wahnsinnig spannend, weil das nämlich automatisch heißt und das ist eigentlich nicht eine Rechtfertigung, aber eine Erklärung für diese schwammigen Begriffe. Das heißt, mit dem falschen Satz, wenn du zu konkret bist, kannst du so eine richtige politische Lawine auslösen, die du überhaupt nicht mehr richtig kontrollieren kannst. Und auch wenn das nur alle 1000 mal passiert oder alle 5 Jahre oder so, ist natürlich die Furcht eines Politikers davor, dass etwas aus seiner Kontrolle rausrutscht, weil er einen falschen Satz gesagt hat, den man hinterher nicht mehr so richtig zurückziehen kann. Die ist groß und ich glaube, die ist nicht ganz unberechtigt groß, weil es natürlich tausend Leute gibt, die im Netz und in den Medien den Politikern noch zehn Jahre später aufs Brot schmieren, was sie da gesagt haben.
Wobei immer mehr sich dieses, was, ich kenne mich nicht mehr, geschätzt von gestern, Ding kultiviert wird. Also jetzt gerade diese Geschichte mit Malmström zur TTIP. Die Kandidatin für die Kommissarwand für die TTIP-Verhandlungen zuständig war, plötzlich in so einer Rede sagte, dass man ja also über diese Sachen mit diesem Investoren-Schutz nochmal nachdenken müsste und so. Also das nicht mehr so Kampfbegriff müssen wir unbedingt haben, dahinter stand und wo dann rauskam, dass offenbar dieser Teil der Rede ihr von Junker Leuten da reingeschrieben wurde und sie quasi die Kontrolle über ihre Rede verloren hat, die vorgelesen hat. Und dann halt irgendwie so dieser, also das hat auf der Ebene halt schon und die dann dementieren musste. Also sie dann gesagt hat, ist ja gar nicht ihre Position hinterher.
Es gibt ja, was auch spannend ist, genau in diesem Kontext, wenn man Phrasen verdammt, wo ich immer gerne dabei bin, weil Phrasen für sich genommen nicht besonders schlimm sind, aber die Haltung, die dahinter steht. Phrasen offenbaren halt sehr häufig eine politisch ganz fragwürdige oder zumindest kontraproduktive Haltung. Aber gerade in Deutschland, Stichwort 1989, kann man sehr gut sehen, wo einzelne Formulierungen im politischen Kontext hinführen kann. Das größte Beispiel der letzten 35 Jahre, was diese Lawine angeht, war ja die Pressekonferenz. Die Maueröffnung. Und wo man heute nachvollziehen kann, dass das an einzelnen Formulierungen lag, die dann sich verselbstimmigt haben, die gar nicht so gemeint waren. Wo dann auch mal, das ist meines Wissens sofort. Und auf einmal stehen die Leute vor der Grenze und du hättest sie nur noch erschießen können, sonst wäre es einfach nicht anders mehr gegangen, die aufzuhalten. Das sind halt so zwei, drei Worte im politischen Kontext, die auf einmal so eine ganze Weltgeschichte irgendwo anders hin.
Wobei man da natürlich argumentieren kann, dass das nur der Anlass war und das ohnehin passiert wäre. Aber gut, letztendlich funktionieren solche Sachen ja immer nur, wenn die Situation schon reif ist. Also du kannst so was eigentlich nur höchst selten gegen den Strom tun.
Ja, aber...
Aber du kannst den Strom deutlich lenken und beschleunigen damit.
Vielleicht ist da auch gegen den Strom nicht die Metapher, sondern eher so Funke und Benzin. Weißt du, ein Kanister Benzin, der steht fünf Jahre da, passiert nichts. Und irgendwann fällt er um und dann ist halt ein Funke da oder nicht. Und diese... mit Metaphern kann man ja eh nur immer so ganz hilfsweise erklären, was los ist. Aber auf jeden Fall glaube ich, dass die Macht von solchen politischen Wendungen und Begriffen größer ist, als man das so glaubt. Übrigens auch deswegen, weil das meine einzige Waffe ist. Und ich komme ja nicht um die Ecke und sage, hey, die einzige Waffe, die ich bedienen kann, ist eigentlich ein machtloser Quatsch.
Hier sind meine Lobby-Millionen. Ob das mal da irgendwie anders ist.
Die ich ohne Hemmung einsetzen würde, wenn ich das hätte, übrigens, das nur nebenbei.
Also das wollte ich auch nicht andeuten, dass die Phrasen von irgendwelchen Masterminds ersonnen werden und die Frage, ob das in irgendwelchen Seminaren verbreitet wird, ist auch nicht die Frage, ob es da einen zentralen Indoktrinator gibt, sondern uns interessiert einfach, wie sich sowas verbreitet. Weil wir möchten gern verstehen, wie das funktioniert. Übrigens ist das nicht nur in der Politik so, sondern auch in großen Firmen funktioniert das genauso. Also man konnte das ganz gut bei...
So Business-Phrasen...
Genau, Business-Phrasen, Industrie 4.0 ist so gerade das Ding. Ich erinnere mich noch an ein Meeting, was wir mit dem Schirrmann hatten, wo er meinte, die FAZ müsse jetzt angefasst werden, die Webseite, um sie HTML5-fähig zu machen. Das ist auch so ein Ding. Das hat er einfach gehört und dachte, da ist jetzt das jetzt Not am Mann, weil es einfach so ein Ding war, da würde ich... So ein Leuchtturmwort, will ich es mal nennen, wo dann plötzlich alle denken, okay, das habe ich noch gar nicht auf dem Radar, da muss ich jetzt auch...
Ja, wobei das noch, da würde ich gerne fein justieren, weil ich habe das gar nicht so bekannt, aber ich habe anderthalb Jahre ungefähr als Berater gearbeitet und zwar so richtig als Consultant im nicht ganz klassischen Sinn, sondern als Senior Advisor bei der Firma Roland Berger.
Ach du meine Güte.
Ja, war eine interessante Erfahrung. Also war auf jeden Fall interessant insofern, als dass ich da was völlig anderes erwartet habe tatsächlich. Aber ich habe es ausprobiert, das hat nicht so funktioniert. Die können was anderes als ich erwartet habe und ich konnte was, was sie nicht gut gebrauchen konnten. Aber egal. Was ich aber da gemerkt habe, ist, dass dieses Buzzwording im Wirtschaftsbereich, gerade bei Nicht-Technikern, ganz wichtige Bedeutung hat. Also aus Beratersicht ist das zum Beispiel, dass je häufiger du ein Buzzword wiederholst, desto eher wird ein Budget draus. Also wenn ganz viele Leute sagen, oh ja, HTML5, oh HTML5, wenn die das zehnte mal hören, dann sagen sie, ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt mal Social machen. Das ist eine nicht zu unterschätzende Funktion, weil dadurch, das ist jetzt vielleicht für euch überraschend, aber dadurch Entscheider überzeugt werden können, von der Relevanz einer technischen Entwicklung. Wenn der EDV-Leiter, das ist ja meistens so, dass die noch EDV heißen, in so einem Unternehmen dahin kommen und sagt so, wir brauchen jetzt eine neue Sicherheitsstufe und wir brauchen jetzt irgendwie 857.000 Euro, dann sagt er erstmal, nee, auf keinen Fall, das ist viel zu teuer, kriegen sie doch so hin. Weil er überhaupt nicht checkt, wie wichtig oder unwichtig das ist. Und dann kommen 700 Leute von allen Seiten und sagen ihm immer das gleiche Wort, was eben der EDV-Leiter gesagt hat. Und dann irgendwann denkt er, Moment, das könnte er tatsächlich, also wenn das so viele Leute sagen, also das denkt er natürlich nicht so ausdrücklich, aber in die Richtung geht das, dann spürt er irgendwann durch den häufigen Gebrauch des Wortes, dass da vielleicht doch eine Notwendigkeit besteht. Und dann geht so ein Prozess im Gang. Ähnlich funktioniert es mit Phrasen auch in großen Firmen. Also die haben manchmal Bedeutung, wo man erstmal denkt, diese Phrase ist das dümmste, was ich je gehört habe, aber auch aus technischer Sicht oder sowas.
Dann darum geht es überhaupt nicht.
Sondern?
Das ist so eine Sache, die wirksamsten Phrasen haben überhaupt keinen Wort-Sinn, sondern da geht es nur darum, klingt gut, klingt wichtig. Und manchmal muss es nicht mal wichtig klingen. Also ich habe ein schönes Beispiel mal relativ nah am Entwickler bei Microsoft sehen können. Da hat Bill Gates irgendwann der Presse erzählt in irgendeinem Interview. XML ist ja total cool, das ist die Zukunft. Und daraufhin hat die gesamte Firma, also nicht im Sinne von von oben kommt die Order, sondern alle kleinen Developer haben es gelesen, haben sich gesagt, ich muss jetzt XML machen. Und von einem Tag auf den Nächsten ist da XML ausgerollt worden in einer Größe, die man sich gar nicht vorstellen kann von außen. Einfach, wenn ein so ein Wort kommt, wenn man eine Sache runterdampfen kann auf einen Begriff, dann haben die Leute das Gefühl, das kann man anpacken. Wenn ich aber da eine größere Geschichte erzählen muss und zu sagen, wir müssen das tun, dann müssen wir hier, das geht nicht. Der Punkt ist, dass man die Erscheinen der Komplexität eines Sachverhalts so weit runterdampfen muss, dass die Leute das Gefühl haben, das muss nicht nur gemacht werden und das ist wichtig, sondern es ist auch klein genug, das können wir auch machen. Industrie 4.0 ist auch so ein Ding, da verbergen sich ja Dutzende von Sachen hinter. Aber wenn du das auf einen Begriff runterdampfen kannst, dann kommt nämlich der Shareholder bei der Konferenz und fragt, haben sie eigentlich Industrie 4.0?
Also Industrie 4.0 ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür, weil das ist ja ein PR-Begriff von der Bundesregierung, nur, dass wir uns da...
Ja, das ist ein PR-Begriff der Bundesregierung.
Es funktioniert? Ja, es funktioniert.
Also ich glaube, der wurde strategisch entworfen zusammen mit dem Verband der Maschinenbauer. Aber also noch nicht ganz sicher.
Ich glaube eher Bitkom. Es kommt eher aus der Bitkom-Cbit-Ecke. Aber das ist...
Egal, ja.
Disclaimer, ich hab für die Cbit viel gearbeitet.
Hannover-Messe, das ist ja auch egal. Ist ja letztendlich wurscht.
Funktioniert. Okay, aber der interessante Punkt dabei ist, dass man merkt dann in dem Augenblick, dass so ein Begriff Relevanz gewinnt, wenn Leute auf der fachlichen Ebene anfangen, über die Definition zu streiten. Also wenn sie versuchen, diesen schwammigen, nie als tatsächlich Terminus Technicus gedachten Begriff mit irgendwie einem konkreten Inhalt zu füllen. Also Industrie 4.0 ist genau so ein Ding. Also das ist halt so eine, genau wie Cloud Computing. Cloud Computing ist genauso ein Begriff, also wo du halt einfach, hat eigentlich kein Inhalt, also kein technisch Sachen.
Bedeutet nichts.
Bedeutet nichts. Und deswegen versucht man dann halt irgendwelche Definitionen dafür zu finden. Cyber war auch so ein schöner Begriff, wo halt einfach jeder sich dann eine Definition aus dem Hut zieht und akademische Papiere darüber schreibt und sich darüber streitet, ob das jetzt noch drin ist oder nicht. Ob jetzt bei Industrie 4.0 nur die Vernetzung gemeint ist oder auch, dass die Daten mit dem Werkstück kommen. Diese Bullshit-Diskussionen, die man dann aus diesen Konferenzen echt lange auswalzen kann, die sorgen natürlich auch für Arbeitsplätze.
Nicht nur das, sondern es gibt ja noch so eine übergeordnete Ebene davon. Ich sehe in der Gesellschaft jetzt nicht, ich würde nicht front sagen, das ist zu hart ein Riss oder so ein Graben vielleicht zwischen den Technikern und den Nicht-Technikern. Und nicht nur von der Sachkenntnis her, sondern auch von der Herangehensweise, vom Verständnis her. Also ob das Weltbild jetzt technologiegeprägt ist oder nicht technologiegeprägt. Und da muss man sich vorstellen, und das ist ja auch Teil meines Jobs, den ich in der Gesellschaft habe, dass die ganzen Nicht-Techniker vor dieser ganzen Welt, die sie gerade überrollt, wo sie an allen Ecken und Enden merken, oh, das bestimmt jetzt irgendwie mein Leben, dass sie da davor stehen und überhaupt nicht einordnen können, was was ist. Und die halten sich verzweifelt an einzelnen Begriffen fest und versuchen, so ein bisschen Licht ins Dunkel reinzubringen. Und da helfen solche Begriffe tatsächlich, dass man irgendwie so sagt, ach, das hat damit zu tun, ich kann das zuordnen. Das ist Social Media ist so ein Begriff, der so ganz am Anfang dafür benutzt wurde. Web 2.0 war vorher noch dieser Begriff dafür. Da passiert irgendwas Neues, von dem ich technisch nur sagen kann, was es ist. Ich verstehe nichts von, wenn Experte darüber redet, gar nichts davon. Aber auf einmal habe ich eine Benennung dafür und kann sagen, ah, das ist ja Web 2.0. Ah, okay. Und dann, in welche Richtung das geht, was da technisch dahinter steht, ist dann gar nicht so wichtig.
Eine Subform davon in der Politik sind ja so Begriffe, die quasi eigentlich nach einer metrischen Einheit verlangen. Also zum Beispiel sowas wie Migrationsdruck. Also Migrationsdruck ist halt genauso eine Politik-Phrase, wo man sagen kann, so der Migrationsdruck ist jetzt halt hoch oder ist nicht so hoch. Also man kann sozusagen dem Problem eine Skala zuordnen und sich denn darüber streiten, wie groß das Ausmaß des Problems ist. Aber mit diesem Begriff alleine ist schon klar, dass es da im Prinzip ein potenzielles Problem gibt.
Na eigentlich ist es ja ein Kampfbegriff, der genau erfunden wird, um den Fakt reinzureiben, dass es ein Problem gibt. Du kannst ja auch einfach sagen...
Das Problem etabliert.
Genau, ja, aber da geht es überhaupt nicht im Größenordnung. Es geht nur darum, hör mal, wir haben hier ein Problem.
Genau, aber du diskutierst in dem Augenblick nur noch über die Größenordnung, aber nicht mehr darüber, ob es das Problem ist.
Genau, da ist der Punkt dabei.
Und das Spannende ist jetzt eigentlich, diese beiden Pole, Kampfbegriff und völlig sinnentlierte Phrase, sich dazwischen zu bewegen und mal zu überlegen, hat das was miteinander zu tun? Weil Kampfbegriff ist ja das allergegenteiligste Gegenteil von sinnentlierte Phrase. In einem Kampfbegriff ist ja eine Ideologie, eine Gegenideologie, eine Gruppe, eine anzugreifende Gruppe, ein Ziel, alles mit verankert, also das Gegenteil von der Phrase.
Es gibt noch die Synthese davon aus Kampfbegriff und Hohlphrase, die Killerphrase, wo du halt einfach, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, wo die Diskussion de facto zu Ende ist. Also wo du halt einfach keine Möglichkeit zur sachlichen Diskussion mehr hast, sobald du diesen Begriff nicht an sich angreifst.
Und das sind ja häufig nicht nur Begriffe, sondern auch Themenfelder. Du kannst ja ganz viele Diskussionen in Themenfelder reinbringen, wo halt einfach kein Punkt zu machen ist. Ich habe da eine eigene Erfahrung, die für mich echt prägend war. Ich bin ja jetzt nicht völlig ungeübt im Umgang mit Medien. Das gelingt manchmal besser und manchmal schlechter, aber ich hatte mal eine Zeit lang wahnsinnig viele Anfragen zum Thema Cybermobbing. Und dachte, naja, da gehe ich mal hin und versuche einfach so eine Art aus meiner damaligen Perspektive Position der Vernunft einzunehmen.
Was ja eigentlich alle immer wollen. Das finde ich immer witzig, dass eigentlich niemand da hingeht und sagt, oh die troll ich jetzt mal so richtig.
Das ist ein guter Urteil.
Normalerweise alle Leute glauben von sich, das finde ich eines der größten Missverständnisse in der Politik, dass die Leute mal glauben, der da drüben von der CDU, der ist ja doof, der ist nur hier um mich zu ärgern. Nee, der glaubt, dass er das Richtige tut.
Ja, die glauben alle, dass sie das Richtige tun. Deswegen habe ich auch gesagt, deswegen habe ich Vernunft relativiert. Vernunft ist auch ein ganz problematischer Begriff, weil Vernunft auch so eine moralische Komponente mitbringt. Das ist nicht nur meine Meinung, sondern das ist da drüber noch die einzig richtige und vernünftige Meinung. Das aber nur nebenbei. Ich wollte also da im Sinne einer, sagen wir mal, netzfreundlichen Ideologie hingehen und sagen, das ist Cybermobbing und da gibt es auch die Meinungsfreiheit auf der anderen Seite und man muss... Und dann, ohne dass ich das wusste, steht mir halt gegenüber eine Frau, wo sechs Wochen vorher ihr Kind, Teenager, Mädchen, Selbstmord gemacht hat, weil sie gemobbt wurde im Internet. Da hast du keine Chance und ich finde es auch richtig, dass du da keine Chance hast. Also die Unverschämtheit, die da entstanden ist, in die Schwierigkeit der Situation, in die ich gebracht wurde, die wurde halt durch diese Fernsehleute produziert. Sie haben da gesagt, da gäbe es eine Betroffene. Aber ich habe jetzt Betroffene gesagt. Da ist halt jemand, der sagt, naja, ich wurde getreult. Dann sage ich, ja, ich wurde auch schon getreult. Bei mir stand es auch von der Tür und so. Das ist halt eine völlig andere Ebene. Und dann ist da auf einmal eine Mutter, die ihr Kind verloren hat. Und ich habe halt so Gänsehaut bekommen, habe gesagt, in dem Moment, das geht nicht. Das kann ich nicht machen. Ich kann, selbst wenn sie den größten Unsinn erzählt, kann ich ihr in dem Kontext nicht widersprechen. Was willst du denn jemandem sagen, der gerade sein Kind verloren hat? Das ist doch völlig, da ist doch jede Diskussionsmöglichkeit nicht mehr gegeben und das war so der Moment, wo ich gemerkt habe, Moment, es gibt Themen, da mache ich einfach einen Bogen drum. Da kann man praktisch nur verlieren und das sind nicht nur Personen, die dir gegenüber sitzen, sondern es ist auch so ein Thema, wo, deswegen wird ja so häufig irgendwie das Kinderpornografie-Thema im netzschweren Bereich mit nach vorne gebracht, weil was willst du denn dagegen sagen, wenn du nicht extra vorher nochmal siebenmal betonst, dass eigentlich und es ist gar nicht darüber nur, sondern es ist noch ein anderes Thema. Es gibt also so ein paar Killer-Phrasen, die auch über Killer-Themen funktionieren.
Das ist richtig. Also interessant ist dann halt eben auch, wer solche Dinge dann eben aktiv missbraucht. Also wer dann halt tatsächlich mit...
Da kommt dann wieder die PR-Rutsche. Da sind wir ja bei den Netzsperren wieder ganz nett.
Also ich fand ja immer sehr traurig, dass die Opposition zwar...
Da kann der Satz schon aufhören.
Nein, nein, nein. Ja gut, die Opposition ist auch traurig, das will ich einräumen, aber irgendwann... Ich hab mir eine Weile lang unter der Annahme operiert, dass ich mir dachte, die Opposition, die ist jetzt dagegen, weil das Gesetz scheiße ist. Aber das stimmt halt nicht, sondern die sind dagegen, weil das ein Gesetz ist, was von der Regierung vorgeschlagen wurde. Sobald die an der Macht sind, wollen die das auch haben. Und nicht nur das. Auch die Argumente, die sie bringen, sind alle total phrasenhaft. Man sieht es häufig. Es gibt so zwei Killer-Dinger, mit denen du immer irgendwie auch in alles andere nicht geht. Greifst du an, entweder mit ja, was ist ja mit den Arbeitsplätzen oder wie finanzieren wir das? Das sind immer so die beiden Sachen. Wenn du die hörst, weißt du, naja gut, dann können wir jetzt auch aufhören, um dir inhaltlich nichts vorzubringen. Und diese Idee, sobald ich das eingesehen habe, dass die Opposition, selbst wenn sie mich jetzt einlädt als Experte, dass es denen wirklich gar nicht inhaltlich um die Sache geht, das würde ich so pauschalisierend nicht sagen.
So pauschal kann man es tatsächlich nicht sagen.
Nein, aber der Eindruck hat sich aufgedrängt einfach, dass der Großteil der Kritik der Opposition an Gesetzen nichts mit dem Inhalt zu tun hatte, sondern dass sie nicht drauf gekommen waren.
Also der Punkt ist halt, die Rolle der Opposition ist ja eben durchaus auch die Kritik. Die Rolle der Opposition im parlamentarischen System besteht ja eben genau darin, die Punkte an Regierungsvorhaben zu finden, die halt möglicherweise zweifelhaft oder falsch sind und auf denen rumzuhacken.
Das muss man auch ein bisschen eher noch als Wachschalenprinzip begreifen. Ich bin bei dir, dass man nicht erwarten kann, dass wenn die Opposition in die Macht kommt, dass die in diesen ganzen Punkten, wo man vorher dachte, um Gottes willen, wie bescheuert ist das denn, die auf einmal anfangen, das Gegenteil zu machen, nur weil sie es vorher kritisiert haben. Aber natürlich ist erstmal nicht richtig zu finden, was die Regierung macht.
Na, aber ist das nicht furchtbar? Ich meine, ist das nicht absolut furchtbar? Viel schlimmer ist eigentlich, dass du denkst, du hilfst denen, anderen kommen sie an die Macht und machen das selber.
Viel schlimmer ist aber eigentlich, was wir gerade in Deutschland haben, dass die prinzipielle Ablehnung von logischen und guten Vorschlägen durch die Regierung, wenn sie von der Opposition kommt, spezifisch von den Linken.
Andersrum auch, andersrum auch. Die Opposition ist auch gegen Gesetze, die eigentlich okay sind, die eigentlich Sachen sind, die sie vorher gefordert haben. Sogar das hat es schon gegeben, nur weil es jetzt von der Regierung kommt. Und das finde ich absolut entsetzlich an unserem System.
Nee, aber da zum Beispiel muss ich jetzt alle Beteiligenden Schutz nehmen. Ernsthaft, es gibt gerade, was Merkel perfektioniert hat, und das steht ja auch überall, es ist überhaupt kein Geheimnis, ist gut klingende oder gut funktionierende Konzepte von anderen Parteien und zwar ungefähr fast allen Parteien einfach zu adaptieren und dann als eigene Leistung auszugeben. Das ist ein relativ häufiges Phänomen, dass man so ein bisschen wartet und dann sagt man, das Konzept war eigentlich ganz gut, das sagt man natürlich nicht öffentlich, sondern nimmt das Gleiche nochmal. Und wenn man dann auf der anderen Seite steht, so ein Ding entwickelt hat, das wurde abgeschmettert von der Regierung und dann kommt die Regierung und tut, als wäre es die eigene Idee gewesen und bringt es noch mal nach vorne, dass man dann nicht begeistert zustimmt, das kann ich ungefähr nachvollziehen. Also, dass man dann ein bisschen merkt, also das ist doch eine Verarschung, warum habt ihr nicht vorher darauf reagiert?
Also, wenn ein Politiker Konzepte von mir klaut, ohne mich zu zitieren, freue ich mich, wenn ich mir eine Kerbe ins Keyboard sage, hey, habe ich noch was geschafft?
Ja, aber du bist ja auch nicht Teil dieses politischen Zirkus.
Aber die werden doch alle bezahlt, ob sie jetzt an der Regierung sind oder in der Position.
Du wirst halt sein, dass nicht auch gleichzeitig Menschen, das sind halt Menschen, die ihre Eitelkeiten haben, die im Zweifel, das weißt du selber, einfach sehr entscheidend sein können, wenn sich jemand unfair behandelt fühlt, wenn jemand da irgendwie nicht die Credits bekommt, die er eigentlich glaubt, verdient zu haben, dann wird der total fuchsig und dann kannst du ihm vorlegen, was du möchtest und das ist dann schlimm. Ich würde ein bisschen davon warnen, die Politik zu sehr als so formalisiert das System zu betrachten. Da sind halt wahnsinnig häufig Menschen mit ziemlich erheblichen Defekten mit beteiligt und diese Defekte, diese charakterlichen, sagen wir mal, zugegenermaßen ist das ein wichtiges Argument. Schwierigkeiten, die führen halt häufig dazu, dass eigentlich logisch auf der Hand liegende rationale Entscheidungen völlig anders fallen, weil die halt emotional quer schießen. Das ist jedenfalls meine Erfahrung und auch im direkten Austausch mit einzelnen Politikern.
Ja, ich habe das halt ein paar mal sehr nah beobachten können. Also die eine Anekdote habe ich glaube ich auch schon ein paar mal erzählt hier, als ich da in diesem Ausschuss angehört wurde als Experte und die mich da mit den Worten begrüßten freut uns, dass sie wieder alle da sind, nachdem wir sie schon die letzten zehn mal ignoriert haben. Dieses Gefühl drängt sich bei mir einfach auf, dass da alle möglichen Dinge einfach getan werden, damit es keine formale Einspruchsmöglichkeit gibt, nicht um tatsächlich Experten anzuhören.
Na und dann wieder, das kann so sein, da würde ich überhaupt nicht leugnen, dass das nicht sogar häufig der Fall ist, aber dann wieder ist meine Erfahrung und das war mit die ernüchterndste Erfahrung, die ich im ganzen politischen Kontext gemacht habe, dass diese, was ich ganz am Anfang gesagt habe, dass das Politikbrett noch viel dicker ist, als man befürchtet, dass das leider wahr ist aus ganz vielen Sichten. Das ist so ein zähes und behäbiges System, wo es so viele Korrektive gibt, die es immer wieder auf den gewohnten Gang zurückzwingen und wo auch einzelne Konzepte kaum wegzutreiben sind. Ich fürchte, man hört wirklich zehnmal Leute an und jedes Mal gibt es vielleicht ein bisschen Überzeugungskraft und am Ende reicht es immer noch nicht.
Es kann trotzdem sein, dass etwas passiert ist, auch wenn es gibt aber eine Zeit, wo es ganz schnell geht, nämlich kurz vor Ende der, wie heißt es kurz vor der Parlamentspause, weil dann verfallen Gesetzesentwürfe, wenn sie bis da nicht durchgewunken sind und dann geht plötzlich alles ganz schnell und Sachen, die seit Monaten rumliegen. Daher kann ich das einfach inhaltlich nicht gelten lassen, dieses Argument, weil es nämlich plötzlich ganz schnell geht, wenn sie das Gefühl haben, so ansonsten geht es gar nicht mehr.
Also wenn es den größten Druck der Öffentlichkeit gibt.
Nein, der größte Scheiß wird irgendwie durchgewunken.
Also kurz vor der Sommerpause und zum Ende der Listaturperiode. Da gehen dann plötzlich Gesetzesentwürfe durch, die ganz objektiv noch nicht genug korrektiv hatten. Und am Anfang der Periode. Aber in der Mitte ist es halt tatsächlich so, da werden die Bretter halt einfach dicker, weil alle haben das Gefühl, Zeit zu haben und wir ja nichts falsch machen. Die nächsten Wahlen kommen ja wieder und so. Insofern stimmt es schon mit den Persönlichkeiten und deren Defekten, meinst, spielt tatsächlich eine sehr viel größere Rolle, als man immer so denken mag, auch eben was so die kleinen Eitelkeiten halt so im Alltag des Parlaments oder den Ministerien angeht. Oder die sind ja doch alle eher, ja, ausschlaggebend für das Verhalten der Menschen dort.
Das finde ich aber eine hoffnungsvolle These, ehrlich gesagt. Denn das heißt, wenn du diese Eitelkeiten kennst, kannst du sie nutzen.
Ja, aber das ist für mich nicht hopfig.
Es geht halt immer um die Aufmerksamkeit der Mächtigen.
Also was genutzt wird, wenn man vom politischen System jetzt in Deutschland ausgeht, was tatsächlich genutzt wird, sind genau diese Zeitabläufe, das direkt ein Gesetz, was zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, an einem bestimmten Ort des Systems prozessiert wird, hat eine größere Chance, ungeprüft schnell durchzurutschen. Das hat es ja eben schon gesagt. Und da gibt es tatsächlich Leute in den Ministerien, die dann so Sachen verzögern oder nach vorne schieben oder erst mal so ein Quatschgesetz nach vorne bringen und damit der zweite Entwurf gerade durchgeht, weil die Leute sich da nicht mehr trauen, das Ganze zerflücken, weil sonst überhaupt nicht mehr usw. Den Versuch, solche Timings zu nutzen, den gibt es auf jeden Fall und da habe ich auch schon Politiker drüber sprechen, hören, wie sie versuchen, sowas zu tun. Aber, und das muss man eben auch sehen, dass es ein so komplexes und so vielschichtiges System, was jederzeit komplett auseinanderfliegen kann, dass man es tatsächlich, egal an welcher Position man sitzt, immer nur versuchen kann.
Das ist halt nicht deterministisch, ja.
Es ist halt nicht so, dass du sagst, okay, wenn wir es am 27. reinschieben und dann kommt es irgendwie ins Kabinett und dann das und dann streichen die Paragraph C und dann geht unser Passage in Paragraph A, geht dann durch. So ist es halt gerade voll nicht, sondern es ist halt immer so ein Vabonspiel von allen Seiten.
Interessante Frage ist ja, wenn Leute so antreten, mit dem Vorsatz, alles zu ändern, nehmen wir mal Obama zum Beispiel. Obama ist ja angetreten mit, wir räumen jetzt mal irgendwie alles auf. Wir machen Guantanamo zu.
Wir hören mit den Kriegen auf.
Wir hören mit der Folter auf.
Und wir machen ja die transparenteste Regierung aller Zeiten.
Auf eine Art hat es ja auch dank Snowden dann stattgefunden.
Das amerikanische politische System ist nochmal deutlich kaputt als unseres. Aber die Frage ist ja dann doch am Ende, wenn so ein Politiker antritt, mit wie räumen wir jetzt mal auf? Das kommt ja immer wieder vor. Alle paar Jahre gibt es mal einen, der sagt, wir müssen jetzt hier mal irgendwie einen krassen Sturz machen, auch in den Ländern, also bei Landtagswahlen, das ist ja durchaus auch wieder der Fall. Oder jemand zum Ministerium komplett neu übernimmt, wo halt irgendwie schon klar ist, dass der Dungenhaufen eher groß ist. Bundeswehr zum Beispiel. Und dann macht man halt mal so Kassensturz und guckt sich das alles an. Und dann trifft man ja offensichtlich immer wieder auf so Dinge, also wo die objektive Realität schon so hingebogen und geshaped wurde, dass man diese Dinge gar nicht mehr ändern kann. Also Guantanamo, der ist ja angetreten, mitmachen wir zu, so auch erst mal ganz einfach raus, kann er einfach ran und wir machen den Laden dann mal zu. Und dann kamen da offensichtlich irgendwie die Leute aus den schattigen Keller und haben ihm mal irgendwie die Welt erklärt. Und dann ging es plötzlich doch nicht mehr so einfach.
Also ich glaube, Guantanamo ist dafür ein besonders schlechtes Beispiel, ehrlich gesagt, weil da man viel zu wenig über die Hintergründe weiß. Auch wenn scheinbar sehr viel klar ist bei Guantanamo. Und wenn man das als Black Box betrachten würde, würde man vollkommen klar sein, es ist einfach völkerrechtswidrig. Es ist alles alles rechtswidrig. Du musst erst mal ein Gesetz finden, wogegen Guantanamo nicht verstößt, so ungefähr. Vielleicht die Verkehrsordnung. Auch da würde ich bezweifeln, dass es da nicht noch... Ich glaube aber, genau deshalb ist es schwierig als Beispiel, weil es eigentlich ein Quick Win sein könnte, theoretisch. Eigentlich ist ein riesiges Rätsel, warum er das nicht einfach tut, weil er so viele Ausweichmöglichkeiten haben könnte und auch würde. Ein Rätsel ist halt kein gutes Beispiel.
Ich finde es insofern wichtig, weil man häufiger die wahrgenommene Komplexität von solchen Themen, und zwar aus der Perspektive desjenigen, der die Entscheidung treffen muss, häufig ja überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann, weil da eine Menge Details drin sind, die auch politische Sachen sein können. Zum Beispiel, dass er irgendwie Leute dafür braucht, die ihm gerade keinen Gefallen mehr schulden, zum Beispiel, oder den eher eigentlich einen Gefallen schuldet. Oder dass du juristische Einschränkungen hast, die gerade in den USA halt im Geheimbereich sind.
Das ist eben, weil da so viel im Geheimbereich und bei Guadalupe-Namo ja auch quasi offiziell im Geheimbereich stattfindet. Deswegen finde ich das Beispiel nicht so richtig gelungen.
Was wäre dann ein gutes Beispiel? Um mal genau dieses Problem, das ist halt also...
Ein gutes Beispiel wäre, glaube ich, die Maut. Die Maut? Ja, und zwar aus mehrerer Hinsicht. Zum einen glaube ich, dass die Maut wirklich in so einer bierseligen Keller-Situation entstanden ist, wo irgendwie ein paar CSU-Leute zusammensaßen und gesagt haben, wir brauchen jetzt irgendwie ein neues großes Projekt und Deutschland kommt voran und dann... Ich kann nicht Bayerisch... Irgendwie Maut. So nehmen wir doch die Maut. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich praktisch zufällig entstanden.
Ich habe da eine zynische Sicht drauf. Ich glaube, das ist entstanden, weil jemand... Seehofer ist so ein Königstyp. Der denkt tatsächlich, ist einer der wenigen Politiker, glaube ich, die langfristig denken. Und der hat gesagt, hör mal, wir haben hier ein Defizit. Wir müssen hier irgendwie langfristig Kohle ranbringen. Wir können hier nicht weiter das Silber verkaufen. Wir machen jetzt Maut und der wird prompt bestraft dafür.
Dagegen spricht, dass von Anfang an fast alle gemerkt haben, dass wenn man das zweite Versprechen, was implizit gemacht wurde, nämlich die Autofahrer, werden nicht stärker belastet, dass man dann damit gar nicht Geld verdienen kann. Die Maut ist ja von Anfang an mit dem populistischen Ansatz gefahren. Wir machen eine Maut, aber niemand muss mehr bezahlen.
Außer die Ausländer.
Außer die Ausländer, aber niemand ist im CSU-Sinn auch ohne Ausländer. Die Frage, die sich dann stellt, ist zu allererst, warum?
Eine Industrieförderung, ist doch klar.
Nein, das ist, glaube ich, nicht immer die richtige Antwort.
Das fiel dann relativ zügig runter. Interessant daran ist ja, dass da erst mal strategisch der ADAC entkernt wurde, damit es keinen politischen Widerstand gibt gegen die Maut. Das ist ja schon eher so ein großer Move, den ADAC irgendwie.
Aber ich glaube zum Beispiel, das hat nichts miteinander zu tun.
Also ich glaube schon. Also da ist halt eigentlich vollkommen klar, dass da ist der zeitliche Ablauf zu eng und zu offensichtlich.
Aber da bin ich zum Beispiel, okay, da sitze ich mit euch beiden auch genau den falschen gegenüber, aber da bin ich anti-verschwörungstheoretiker in dem Kontext, dass bis da nicht sehr starke Hinweise außer dem zeitlichen Kontext drauf existieren, das dann zu haben besteht, gehe ich erstmal davon aus, dass keiner besteht.
Also wenn ich dir die Indizien mal zeitlich aufmale, dann haben wir halt irgendwie...
Es gibt ja mehrere ADAC-Skandale, das war ja nicht nur ein Ding.
Der Punkt ist halt, dass wenn du mit Leuten redest, die halt diesen ADAC-Kontext ein bisschen genauer betrachten, die wussten das alle schon. Also diese ganzen Skandale, die waren quasi so eine Dinge, die alle, die sich mit dem Thema befasst haben, haben es ungefähr gewusst, man hat die Details nicht so genau gewusst und niemand hat darüber geredet, weil alle viel davon hatten, die Schnauze zu halten.
Ja, aber da möchte ich jetzt mehrere Sachen auseinanderhalten. Also zum einen glaube ich nicht, dass nur um eine Maut durchzuprügeln, man einen extrem treuen CSU-Unterstützerverband, der ADAC in München war halt immer voll CSU, weil alle in München CSU waren, dass man den deswegen über die Klinge springen lässt. Das wäre der erste Punkt. Der zweite Punkt, von dem ich, wo ich ein bisschen skeptisch bin, insgesamt ist, dass die Art und Weise, wie das passiert ist bei dem ADAC, die spricht eine ganz andere Sprache. Ich habe da mal ansatzweise fünf Sätze verloren drüber in der Kolumne. Interessanterweise glaube ich, dass da das Internet daran schuld ist. Die Story vom ADAC ist, wir vertreten 19 Millionen Autofahrer oder so und so viel mehr. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es genauso ist, aber es sind fast 20 Millionen. Das bedeutet aber gleichzeitig, wenn der ADAC die vertritt, dass nicht nur die Leute da die Versicherung wahrnehmen, sondern dass sie auch eine Mobilisierungsmacht haben. Der ADAC hat seinen Machtstatus darauf begründet, zu sagen, wir stehen für die Autofahrer, die Autofahrer stehen hinter uns. Das bedeutet, wenn immer wir irgendwas machen wollen, dann sind hinter uns 19 Millionen Leute. Und das ist das Narrativ, mit dem sie in der Öffentlichkeit aufgetreten sind. Und wenn du so ein Narrativ hast und an deiner verdammten Abstimmung nehmen einfach 415 Leute teil, dann hast du ein verdammtes Problem.
Welche Abstimmung war das?
Das war die Abstimmung zum Auto des Jahres. Das bedeutet, das war der erste der Initiale. Das heißt, ich glaube, der ist entstanden so ein bisschen aus dem Gefühl, dass der ADAC es sich nicht leisten kann, seine wichtigste Veranstaltung, oder eine seiner wichtigsten Veranstaltungen, nämlich das Auto des Jahres. Das ist ganz wichtig, immer riesen ADAC-Artikel zu machen. Und von den 19 Millionen Leuten interessiert ist faktisch unter 0,1 Promille, also niemanden, weil das ein Signal nach außen sendet, ihr könnt eure Leute nicht mobilisieren. Die sind beim ADAC, weil sie auf der Autobahn abgeschleppt werden, so wie ich glaube, dass es auch ist. Dich interessiert ja ein Scheiß, was die für einen Lobbykram machen. Du willst einfach auf der Autobahn irgendwie jemanden anrufen, da kommt halt ein gelliger Engel und fertig. Ich glaube, es ist einfach so eine Service-Veranstaltung gewesen, warum die Leute da Mitglied sind. Aber das ist eben nicht das Narrativ, mit dem sie aufgetreten sind. Und deswegen haben sie angefangen zu fälschen. Und ich bin da ziemlich sicher.
Ich glaube, dass genau diese Enttarnung dieses Skandals, also dass das dem so war, war eigentlich vielen Leuten schon sehr lange klar. Und diesen Punkt sozusagen nachzuweisen, dass der Kaiser keine Kleider anhat an der Stelle, der hätte zu jedem beliebigen Zeitpunkt passieren können. Also da gab es irgendwie keine, der hätte vor zwei Jahren passieren können, hätte in drei Jahren passieren können. Das war eigentlich so eine Bombe, die lag auf dem Tisch. Und da hätte man eigentlich nur einen Timecode eingeben müssen und dann ging die hoch.
Aber das wurde ja von einem Medium aufgebracht, der ADAC-Skandal.
Der wurde von einem Medium aufgebracht, die von jemandem darauf hingewiesen wurden.
Ich lasse dir deine Verschwörungstheorie.
Also der Faktor war, dass er freundlich ist.
Schmeckt so ein bisschen nach, schönen Club haben sie da. Puff, seid ihr immer noch gegen die Maut.
Ihr seid immer noch gegen die Maut.
Seid ihr jetzt immer noch gegen die Maut?
Nein. Und ihr seid immer noch gegen die Maut. So schmeckt es einfach. Maut ist ja, also zumindest zum damaligen Zeitpunkt war die Maut ja jetzt auch nicht eine Religion für die CSU. Die ist inzwischen jetzt so eine Religion geworden, aber ich glaube nicht, da fehlt die Verhältnismäßigkeit. Das ist für mich nicht ein gültiges Indiz.
Na ja, es gab ja da durchaus intensivere Diskussionen, auch unter Teilnahme des ADAC. Also bei einer war ich tatsächlich zugegen, da ging es darum, wie die technische Ausführung dieser Maut aussehen wird. Und weil die hatten halt da so Ideen so mit On-Board-Units und so, also quasi wie die Lkw-Maut, die halt runterzuskalieren auf PKW. Und dann waren halt so Industrievertreter, die halt irgendwie meinten halt so und ja, und wir haben jetzt diese On-Board-Unit-Technologie und die ist total super und toll, weil damit kann man auch Landstraßen tarifieren und so weiter und so fort. Und wir können halt irgendwie verkehrsabhängige Maut machen, also streckenabhängige Maut. Und so, und dann war dann halt noch so ein Typ vom BKA, der irgendwie nur mühsam seinen Saba zurückhalten konnte und meinte irgendwie, ja, mit diesen On-Board-Units ist das irgendwie echt eine gute Sache und so. Und dann war der Typ vom ADAC und der sagte ja, naja, also sie haben da so drei Grundpositionen. Die erste ist halt nichts, was irgendwie die Lokation eines Autofahrers überwacht, weil irgendwie das verstößt halt gegen Mobilitätsfreiheit. Zweite Position, irgendwie keine Belastung von Autofahrern durch Investitionen ins Fahrzeug. Dritte Position, wir brauchen halt maximal, wenn überhaupt irgendwas geht, dann maximal irgendwas, was kosteneutral für die Autofahrer ist. Und das hat er dann vorgetragen im Namen seiner 19 Millionen Mitglieder. Und in diesem Punkt hat er wahrscheinlich sogar für seine 19 Millionen Mitglieder gesprochen. Also der hat tatsächlich da an der Stelle nicht mal irgendwie sozusagen, also an der Stelle hätten sie wahrscheinlich wirklich eine Mobilisierung zustande bekommen. Wenn es dazu gekommen wäre, dass irgendwie das so eine 500 Euro musste investieren, damit auf der Autobahn fahren kann, es nochmal gewesen wäre, dann hätte der ADAC da Leute mit Fakten und Missgrabben vom Kanzleramt, aber ganz definitiv. Und am Ende ist es ja interessanterweise so, dass die ja trotzdem mit den Positionen sich ja im Wesentlichen durchgesetzt haben. Die haben ja gesagt, es gibt halt, also Obo-Unit wird nicht mehr diskutiert, Tracking wird nicht diskutiert. Alles, worüber wir reden, sind halt irgendwie Beppe, so im Wesentlichen. Und da haben sie gesagt, das wäre halt unsere Rückfallposition, da können wir maximal so drüber reden. Aber war sozusagen seine maximale Vorstellung, eigentlich sind wir dagegen. Das ist irgendwie eigentlich eine scheiß Idee. Wir wollen das nicht. Und EU-Rechnen hat dann so die ganzen normalen Argumente, die jetzt auch nicht gebraucht werden.
Aber wir kamen ja eigentlich von der Diskussion her, nicht von der Verschwörungstheorie und der zufälligen oder nicht zufälligen Konzidenz von solchen Sachen, wo ich halt immer der Meinung bin, man sollte erstmal von der Zufälligkeit ausgehen, sondern wir kamen ja eigentlich vom Beherrungsvermögen eines Systemes. Da möchte jemand was ändern und ich habe tatsächlich selber geglaubt und dass Obama am Anfang das ändern wollte. Also ich habe vom reinen Gefühl, ich kann das überhaupt nicht auf irgendwelchen Fakten gründen. Vom reinen Gefühl dachte ich tatsächlich...
Der wird einfach ehrlich, am Anfang haben die Leute dem geglaubt. Ich meine, der hat ja den Friedensnummerpreis gekriegt.
Also ich glaube am Anfang.
Nicht nur wir haben dem geglaubt.
Also Freunde von mir waren in Amiland sehr involviert in diese Hope-Kampagne, die es nur noch als Satire gibt. Also diese Kampagne mit Obama und Hope, die war ernsthaft. Mit diesem stylisierten Obama-Gesicht, mit dem, was wir jetzt nur noch von den Snowden-Aufklebern kennen, war ja ursprünglich mal eine echte, ernsthafte Obama-Kampagne. Und das war ja auch so, dass das intellektuell so vorgebracht wurde. Also das war ja tatsächlich nicht nur eine PR-Kampagne, sondern tatsächlich so ein Rebuild America. Zurück zu unseren Werten. Wir müssen unsere liberalen Werte und so weiter. Also wir wollen uns nicht länger von diesen Rednecks diktieren lassen, was Amerika ist. Das war ja eigentlich das Movement dabei. Und die haben sie doch ernst gemeint. Also für die war das tatsächlich so eine richtige Religion quasi geworden.
Na, der drängte ja auch nach acht Jahren Busch.
Genau. Und der Punkt, der jetzt da passiert ist, ist eigentlich so schlimm, weil diese Leute wollen Politik nichts mehr zu tun haben. Die sagen, Politik machen wir wieder, wenn da draußen die Barrikaden brennen, dann gehen wir raus. So, weil vorher ist mit Hoffnung in irgendwelche Politiker hat sich erledigt.
Ja, also das hoffen mich leider, da muss man fast dankbar sein, dass man da in Deutschland lebt, wo das auch schlimm ist, aber sagen wir mal auf einer verständlichen Ebene schlimm. Da ist es ja auf einer völlig nicht mehr nachvollziehbaren, irrationalen Weise vergiftet. Was natürlich mit diesen sehr, sehr komplexen und auch gar nicht so einfach verständlichen Politik-Ebenen in den Vereinigten Staaten zu tun hat. Also dadurch, dass es da nur zwei Parteien gibt, gibt es halt die vielen unterschiedlichen Strömungen, die dann auf sehr überraschende Weise so eine Art politische Richtung festlegen oder dagegen kämpfen, die für Außenstehende kaum mehr richtig nachvollziehbar ist, bis auf die oberflächlichsten Positionen.
Aber ich meine, das war der Charme der Obama-Kampagne, dass sie eigentlich einfache, klare Selbstverständlichkeiten, also relativ simple Ansätze, die sagen, wir drehen den Unsinn der letzten, ach ja, passiert das wieder um, so wir gehen kern zurück zu einer rationalen Politik, zu einer ergebnisorientierten Politik. Also so wie man halt, also die ursprüngliche Obama-Kampagne war ja so, dass man so boar geil, so kann Politik sein, so können Leute irgendwie vorangehen und irgendwie Ideen vortragen, so kann man irgendwie auch Politik vermarkten.
Das ist ja richtig auch als Mem nach Deutschland gespült.
Jaja, total.
Also dass hier Parteien versucht haben, sich Schulen zu lassen, wie sie mehr wie Obama auftreten können, wo ich auch nur gedacht hab.
Ja gut, plus der Punkt war, also der Unterschied dazu war ja, dass die Inhalte hier waren ja eher vergleichsweise, naja, die Unterschiede sind halt nicht so groß.
Aber wir haben halt auch keinen Busch gehabt vorher.
Wir haben halt keinen Busch gehabt vorher. Also bei uns war es, also die Lage zwar scheiße, aber jetzt nicht so schlimm wie da. Und was jetzt aber ja passiert ist, dass er in nur sehr, sehr wenigen Politikfällen überhaupt irgendwas bewegt bekommen hat. Und man kann es natürlich zum Teil schieben auf die spezifischen Zustände des amerikanischen Systems mit irgendwie Deadlock im Senat und Repräsentantenhaus und so weiter. Aber dass er selbst in Punkten, wo es diese Notwendigkeit nicht gab, also wo es rein administrative Entscheidungen waren, dass er selbst da überhaupt in keiner Weise zu seinen Versprechungen mehr hält. Das gibt bei mir tatsächlich Anlass zu der Vermutung, dass die ursprüngliche Kampagne nur eine PR-Kampagne war. Dass die Neveler Demografie identifiziert haben, diese mobilisieren mussten, um gegen ihre Politik anzuhöten.
Kann gut sein. Ich glaube, am Ende war es eine Mischung, aus dem Obama tatsächlich etwas verändern wollte. Also ich glaube nicht, dass alles gespielt war. Und dann an den Notwendigkeiten oder vermeintlichen Notwendigkeiten gescheitert ist. Also viel von dem Beherrungsvermögen, was solche politischen Systeme in sich tragen, das ist jedenfalls nach meinem Erleben so, was nicht repräsentativ natürlich ist und auch nur sehr punktuell stattgefunden hat. Aber viel von dem Beherrungsvermögen ist, wenn man mittendrin steht, total einfach nachvollziehbar. Da sind einfach Leute, das sind Abteilungsleiter, die kämpfen um eine Abteilung und über die Abteilung 2b und über deren Budget von 438.000 Euro im Jahr. Plus noch drei Mitarbeiter und eine Referentin. Und die sagen sich, ich muss versuchen, meinen Machtbereich zu erhalten. Ich muss versuchen, meinen Machtbereich auszudehnen, wenn ich das schaffe, aber das ist noch nicht mal die erste Prämisse, sondern ich muss versuchen, weiterzukommen, zu überleben. Und dafür muss ich bestimmte Hebel in Gang setzen. Und dass das ein Ziel von jemandem ist, das kann ich total nachvollziehen, und ich glaube, daraus ergibt sich sehr viel von diesem Beharrungsvermögen. Nämlich daraus, dass Menschen versuchen, in Systemen, in ihre Vorteile zu erhalten. Und dass da dann seltsame politische Folgen und Konsequenzen draus entstehen.
Ich hab ja eine These hier niedergeschrieben, die kann ich ja mal vortragen. Nämlich, dass die Politik vergleichbar ist mit Surfen. Man hat so eine Welle und sobald man auf seinem Brett steht, hat man als Ziel gar nicht mehr zum Strand zu kommen, sondern man ist nur noch sehr kurzfristig damit beschäftigt, nicht nach links zu fallen, nicht nach rechts zu fallen, nicht nach hinten zu fallen. Das heißt, der Horizont der Entscheidung wird reduziert. Die einzige tatsächlich wichtige Aufgabe in der Sekunde ist, nicht mehr runterzufallen.
Also, wenn man diese These ernst nehmen würde, dann würde die ungefähr jeder Verschwörungstheorie total widersprechen. Weil das, was du gerade vorträgst, halt das Gegenteil von einer dunklen Kontrolle von irgendeiner Seite ist, sondern das ist dann wirklich nur Fahnen auf Sicht. Damit kann ich mich sehr gut anfreunden. Also, ich habe jetzt nicht versteckt, dass ich diese verschwörungstheoretischen Ansätze für schwierig oder bis problematisch teilweise sogar halte. Aber diesem Thema kann ich sehr gut folgen.
Das ist keine These für das gesamte System, sondern es ist eine These für den einzelnen Mitspieler. Ja, das ist kein Widerspruch zur Verschwörungstheorie, weil du kannst immer noch postulieren, dass es irgendjemanden gibt, der das ausnutzt. Aber ich glaube, dass die Merkel so operiert, zum Beispiel, oder der Chef an irgendeiner Behörde. Der hat so zwei, drei Punkte, die du gerade schon genannt hast. Der möchte sein Budget erhalten. Der möchte gerne in der Presse erwähnt werden, als jemand, der was Gutes getan hat. Der möchte gerne, wenn irgendeine Katastrophe passiert, möchte er als der Held genannt werden, der halt mit seiner Behörde geholfen hat. Ebola ist passiert, dann möchte gerne die Gesundheitsbehörde, also so, oder was weiß ich, ein Unfall, Polizei. Die möchten halt gerne Anerkennung für ihre Arbeit haben und die möchten gerne überleben. Aber so weitergehende Sachen, wie wir jetzt die Menschheit verbessern, sind da im Wesentlichen nicht.
Das ist nicht meine Erfahrung tatsächlich.
Ich glaube, dass die Merkel, also es mag jetzt nicht bei allen so sein, aber ich glaube, dass die Merkel tatsächlich so regiert. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie sich das ausgedacht hat, weil sie besonders schlau ist, sondern ich glaube, dass da so einen evolutionsähnlichen Prozess gab. Und ich habe mal den versucht, so ein bisschen historisch herzuleiten, habe mir gedacht, war das bei Adenauer eigentlich auch schon so? Ich meine, wir können ja hier nicht so weit zurückgehen in unserem Land. Aber ich habe mir gedacht, eigentlich war das bei Adenauer ziemlich anders. Der hat noch, also habe ich zumindest den Eindruck, wenn ich mir so Filme angucke, dass da wirklich noch Inhalte und persönliche Überzeugungen eine Rolle gespielt haben. Wir müssen jetzt hier gegen die Kommunisten und daraus folgt, wir müssen das und das machen und die Bevölkerung wird uns das schon glauben, wenn sie die Argumente sehen. So damals war das noch mehr eine Zeit und wenn sie es nicht wollen, dann halt nicht, ich bin hier der Kanzler. Also es gab noch Gründe für die Sachen. Während bei der Merkel, glaube ich, das Gegenteil wahrzunehmen, ich sage jetzt noch gar nicht mehr die Gründe, ich versuche nur zu betrachten, wie die Leute regieren und ich glaube, bei der Merkel ist das so eine sehr fast vollständige Abstraktion von den inhaltlichen Punkten und sie sitzt im Grunde da und versucht, im Amt zu bleiben und hat zwei, drei Sachen bemerkt, die schon bei Kohl und Schröder beobachten kann. Kohl hat ja Aussitzen als Strategie erfunden. Er hat einfach gesehen, die Gegenseite, die versucht, mir irgendwas anzuhängen, die hat pro Tag einen Aufwand und wenn ich das einfach aussitze, habe ich keinen Aufwand. Das mache ich jetzt einfach. Und vor Ende der Legislaturperiode kriegen die mich eh nicht weg und in der Zwischenzeit passiert noch irgendwas, dann ist es wieder weg. Das ist eine Strategie, die hat Kohl erkannt, dass das gut ist und funktioniert. Merkel hat noch mehr gemacht, dass sie einfach gesehen hat, wenn ich sage, wir haben jetzt Problem X und ich tue jetzt Y, um Problem X zu bearbeiten, dass ich mir dadurch ein Risiko einfange, was ich nicht haben muss. Wenn ich jetzt Problem X bearbeiten will und dann geht es von alleine weg, bevor ich dazu komme, Y zu machen oder ein Experte kommt und sagt, Y hilft aber gar nicht. Das sind Risiken, die ich nicht haben muss, wenn ich gar nicht erst sage, wie ich versuche, das Problem zu beheben. Wenn ich einfach nur sage, wir werden jetzt was tun, um den Arbeitsmarkt zu verbessern, wir werden jetzt Maßnahmen einleiten. Ich glaube, da kommen diese Hohlphasen her. Dann habe ich dieses Risiko auch nicht, dass ich am Ende rausstellen kann, dass es nichts mit meiner Arbeit zu tun hatte. Merkel kann sich einfach hinstellen und sagen, wir werden jetzt dafür sorgen, dass die Arbeitslosenzahlen runtergehen. Dann kommt die Konjunktur. Jedes Jahr ist dieselbe Kurve. Im Frühling geht es ein bisschen hoch oder runter. Aber innerhalb des Jahres gibt es eine Kurvenbewegung. Wenn Merkel vorher gesagt hat, wir tun jetzt was, und dann sieht man, es ist besser geworden, dann kann sie sich das ankreiden. Sie kann sagen, das haben wir gemacht. Aber wenn sie vorher sagt, wir werden jetzt dies und das tun, dann kann man kommen und sagen, das System ist so träge, das seid ihr gar nicht zu bekommen. Daran kann es nicht gelegen haben. Dieses Risiko geht Merkel einfach nicht mehr ein.
Also den zweiten Teil kann ich nachvollziehen. Da hab ich auch noch ein bisschen feindifferenzierte Meinungen. Aber diesen Adenauer-Teil kann ich gar nicht nachvollziehen, woher du die Information hast. Also ich kenne mich mit dieser Zeit zu wenig aus. Aber die punktuellen Informationen, die ich habe, ich habe mal den Wahlkampf 1957 hinterher recherchiert.
Also es gibt so Videos aus den Parlamentsreden von damals.
Die sagen ja nun nicht alles über das System.
Ich sage das ist auch nur mein Eindruck.
Ich kenne das zu wenig, aber es war auch vor meiner Zeit.
Aber ich glaube, wenn ich diese...
Also der Unterschied, also ich kenne mich in der Zeit zufällig ein bisschen aus.
Du bist ja auch schon so alt, ne?
Nee, ich habe aber tatsächlich nach der Wende, also nachdem ich angefangen habe zu studieren, war ich draußen in einer Außenstelle der FU.
Das Adenauer Kunde betrieben.
So ähnlich, wo es nämlich eine Handausleihe gab von irgendwie Spiegel, Sternen, Quick, bunte, wo man sich hinsetzen konnte, lesen konnte. Ich habe mir links oben angefangen, 46 und unten rechts aufgehört. Und was damals tatsächlich anders war, war nicht, dass die Machtmechanismen anders waren, sondern es war schon genauso, dass es diese Parteiproporz und so richtig war. Die Medienmechanismen waren halt. Und war nicht so schnell. Es gab noch mehr Gekungel und es gab halt auch noch mehr Machtzentren, auch wichtig. Es gab halt noch so die deutschen Nationalen und auch so Zentrum und so, auf die man Rücksicht nehmen musste und die alten Nazis und so. Und man hat aber einen gemeinsamen Feind. Der Unterschied war, dass es tatsächlich noch richtige Probleme gab. Also es gab halt zu wenig Wohnungen. Es gab das Problem, dass irgendwie die Landwirtschaft irgendwie gebootet werden musste. Es gab das Problem, dass man die Aufrüstung irgendwie finanzieren musste und so. Also es gab halt so richtig so.
Und in deinem Kontext gab es halt das Problem, dass nach Meinung der meisten Politologen jedenfalls, dass der Marshallplan, der ja wenig zu tun hatte mit der Regierung, sondern eher so ein übergeordneter Alliiertenplan war, dass der eigentlich das zentrale Moment der Wohlstandsentwicklung war. Und dann ist es, glaube ich, aus meiner Sicht, die wir schon ein Problem, wenn du da als Politiker stehst, der verantwortlich ist und das große Instrument, was die Wohlstandsentwicklung forciert, dass das mit dir gar nicht so viel zu tun hat.
Das ist doch super für die Merkel, das ist perfekt. Der Unterschied ist aber, dass die ideologische Argumentation der Westanbindung hatte eine ökonomische Unterfütterung, nämlich den Marshallplan. Und wenn du eine Rede von Wiener zum Beispiel anguckst aus der Zeit. Also Wiener war ein sehr guter Redner in dem Sinne, dass du merkst, da ist Passion dahinter. Also da ist Reif dabei. So was du heute eigentlich nicht mehr findest. Und das resultiert aber eben aus der persönlichen Geschichte dieser Leute. Also die sind halt wirklich durch die kniettiefe Scheiße gegangen am Krieg. Und die hatten noch alle Geschichten und Dinge zu verbergen, wo klar war, dass wenn das hochkommt, dann wartet mit der Karriere. Und das war denen nicht so egal. Und die hatten auch tiefe Überzeugungen.
Das ist genau der Punkt. Ich möchte mich von der Adenauer Zeit lösen.
Und heutzutage hast du zwar immer noch Leute, die inhaltliche Überzeugungen haben. Also jeder Politiker, mit dem du redest, sagen wir mal, vielleicht auch von Friedrich und ähnlichen CSU-Leuten, die sowieso nur noch in die Partei gegangen sind, weil sie in Österreich niemand haben wollten, in Bayern. Gibt es immer noch Leute, die haben Überzeugungen? Die wollen, Umweltschutz finden sie wichtig oder die finden, dass irgendwie eine Energiewende wirklich eine Sache ist, die man machen muss, jetzt mal, weil sich sorgen um den Planeten machen und so weiter und so fort. Aber das ist mehr so ein Hintergrundrauschen. Das ist tatsächlich so eine...
Das ist nicht meine Erfahrung. Ich sehe tatsächlich, dass bei Merkel diese Überzeugung nicht mehr stattfindet. Und ich glaube auch, dass da...
Nee, Merkel ist eine Ausnahme.
Genau.
Merkel ist schon Postüberzeugung.
Ja, Postüberzeugungspolitik. Was auf eine Art übrigens der Grund ist, warum sie gewählt wird. Weil sie nämlich nicht als Leidenschaftsperson wahrgenommen wird, sondern eben als das Gegenteil des Vernunftspersonens.
Verwaltung.
Das Pragmatische, das machen wir jetzt mal. Wenn das Gegenteil von dem, was ich gestern noch für richtig gehalten habe, morgen notwendig ist, dann mache ich das genau mit der gleichen Kraft, die ist auch so... Also...
Nee, Merkel ist... Ich glaube, das ist sogar noch perfider, weil ich glaube, Merkel wird genau deswegen gewählt, weil die Abwesenheit von Überzeugung Stabilität verspricht.
Ja, das kann gut sein.
Nichts anderes ist... Der Grund, warum du Merkel wählst heutzutage, ist tatsächlich, weil sich möglichst wenig verändern soll.
Also ich wähl nicht Merkel, will ich jemanden zur Protokolle...
Also wenn jemand Merkel wählt, ist der Hauptgrund tatsächlich, dass sich möglichst wenig verändern soll. Und die Abwesenheit von Überzeugung ist eine solide...
Genau, da würde ich dir aber recht geben, dass Merkel die Ausnahme ist. Ich hab die Politiker, die ich kennengelernt habe, die haben tatsächlich Überzeugung. Ich seh die aber nicht als Hintergrundrauschen, sondern wir haben ein sehr überzeugungsaverses politisches System. Das hab ich daran gemerkt, wenn immer ich konfrontiert war damit und wo ich eine Überzeugung hatte. Sagen wir mal, nehmen wir jetzt mal so den Fall gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht zu kämpfen. Oder irgendwie so ein Netzfall, der auch aus Sicht der Internetleute fast völlig eindeutig ist, wo man einfach nur sagen kann, ey, dann müssen sie anders machen. Ich bin da mit einer Überzeugung hingegangen und diese Überzeugung hat letztlich bei meinem Anrennen gegen bestimmte politische Instanzen, einzelne Politiker verwende und was ich da ganz viel Hintergrundarbeit hab ich eine Zeit lang gemacht, die war total kontraproduktiv für mich. Warum? Wenn du mit einer Überzeugung rangehst, dann hast du ein Enttäuschungspotenzial, was viel größer ist und ich glaube, dass deswegen das politische System sehr überzeugungsavers ist, weil du eigentlich sehr oft deine Überzeugung mal für einen Moment zur Seite legen musst. Du musst die entleidenschaftlichen, du musst sagen, ich bin zwar eigentlich für die Abschaffung der Atomkraft, aber ich muss jetzt diesen Vertrag unterschreiben, wo noch zwölf Jahre länger Atomkraft ist, weil die Alternative ist, dass es 20 Jahre länger dauert. Also du musst in der Politik auf eine Weise Kompromisse machen, die dir, wenn du wirklich Überzeugungstäter bist, wirklich Bauchschmerzen machen. Und ich glaube deswegen ist das Überzeugungstäter-Tum in der Politik sehr stark verbreitet und gleichzeitig der Mechanismus, die eigene Überzeugung mal für einen Moment zur Seite zu stellen. Und die Leute, die es nicht können, die kommen nicht in der Politik durch oder die werden geistesgestört oder nehmen Drogen oder werden Alkoholiker oder werden depressiv. In der Politik gibt es wahnsinnig viele Leute, die in diese Richtung Probleme haben, weil diese Politik ist einfach ein Höllenjob. Das darf man nicht unterschätzen. Es ist unfassbar anstrengend. Es ist wahnsinnig gefährlich im Sinne von, du bist halt nur von Leuten mit Knarren umgeben, die dir schaden wollen. Ist dann auch wirklich so, dass Leute auf deinen Stuhl wollen. Also jetzt natürlich im übertragenen Sinne Knarren. Es gibt Leute, die sägen an deinem Stuhl. Und ich glaube, dass deswegen eine wichtige Eigenschaft für die Politik ist, zwar eine Überzeugung zu haben, wo man langfristig für kämpft, die langfristige Motivation, aber kurzfristig diese Überzeugung bis ins Gegenteil verkehren zu können. Einfach als Überlebenstrick.
Das ist ja meine Theorie, was mit Obama passiert ist. Ich glaube, dass er einfach alles für seine Gesundheitsreform geopfert hat.
Was ich als häufiger auch gesehen habe, ist, dass sich das dann zu so einer Meta-Überzeugung wandelt. Das ist dann so was wie in der 100-jährigen Tradition meiner Partei stehend. Man versucht dann halt nicht mehr, das eigentlich Problem zu betrachten, sondern wie es in den Geschichtsbüchern aussehen wird.
Oder noch nicht schlimmer, aber noch ein bisschen schwieriger verständlich, der Rückzug auf das Image. Und zwar wirklich nur zu sagen, wenn die SPD an der Macht ist, ich habe es eben aus der Partei jetzt am häufigsten gehört, wenn die SPD an der Macht ist, dann geht es den Leuten besser. Und auch, wenn ich jetzt gegen meine eigenen Überzeugungen verstoße, wenn es hilft, dass die Partei an der Macht ist und bleibt, dann bin ich zwar derjenige, der jetzt wirklich zu knabbern hat, weil ich meine eigenen Überzeugungen verraten habe, aber ich helfe der großen Sache, weil es der Bundesrepublik besser geht, wenn die SPD an der Macht ist. Also das ist...
Tech One for the Team.
Ja, so ungefähr. Und das ist halt in meinen Augen bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt absolut gerechtfertigt. Ich glaube, bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt geht es gar nicht anders. In der Demokratie, dass man sagt, okay, da konnte ich das nicht ganz durchsetzen und da gebe ich der Richtung nahe. Aber ab einem bestimmten Punkt wird es wirklich eklig.
Wo ist der Punkt?
Kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Aber letztendlich ist das ja genau die Frage. Weil letzten Endes hast du in der Politik, wenn du halt so eine Kompromisse machst, die immer ausgleich ist und so weiter und so fort, versuchst du ja als erstes macht taktisch die Größe des Kompromisses, die du machen musst, also die Größe der Kröte, die du schlucken musst, zu vermindern. Also versuchst du halt irgendwie dafür zu sagen, dass deine Leute an der Macht sind oder dass du halt bestimmte Themen, die dich nicht interessieren, opf hast und so weiter. Das ist ja häufig so, das haben wir ja häufiger gesehen, dass wenn wir also gerade mal so in relativ kleinteiliger Politik unterwegs waren und uns um Gesetzesvorschläge gingen oder um Verordnungen oder so. Und dann wurden Punkte, die uns echt wichtig waren. Also wo wir sagten, okay, hier ist das Kleingedruckte wirklich wichtig. Und das ist der Teil, den ihr wirklich nicht opfern solltet. Also ihr habt irgendwie hier und hier sind Opferzonen. Da könnt ihr irgendwie möglicherweise reingehen.
Opferzone, Unvor 2015 oder so.
Also hier sind sozusagen die, da haben wir jetzt nicht so groß Probleme. Aber hier sind so die fünf Kernbereiche. Wenn er da reingeht, dann lass es lieber ganz. Und unweigerlich immer kommen von so fünf Kernbereichen mindestens zwei unter die Räder, wo die andere Seite genau versteht, dass es darum eigentlich geht. Also dass da eigentlich das politische Ziel ist, um das es geht. Und dann aber mit allen Tricks, die da so da sind, versucht, den Kompromissraum so weit aufzuziehen, dass du sagst, okay, aber wir müssten jetzt an der Stelle noch und dann haben wir noch dieses disjunkte Thema und übrigens schuldet uns da noch ein Gefallen.
Das ist auch, dass diese Kreuz und quer, also dieses Cross Selling könnte man es nennen. Das ist übrigens auch ein wichtiger Punkt, wo man sich einfach von Überzeugungen verabschiedet und dafür etwas anderes bekommt, was vordergründig oder auch hintergründig damit nichts tun hat, außer dass man eben Tauschmasse braucht. Das ist ja auch ein zentraler Kritikpunkt, den ich von der Kolumne auf Spiegel Online von Merkel geübt habe, dass sie halt wirklich alles als politische Tauschmasse betrachtet. Alles. Es gibt nichts, was sie nicht als politische Tauschmasse betrachtet. Und in einer bestimmten Form der Politik ist das sogar extrem klug. Und zwar genau in der Form, dass deine Feinde wissen, die Dinge, die du als nicht verhandelbar betrachtest, sind deine wunden Punkte. Insofern ist diese vorgehensweise erstmal zu sagen, wir können über alles reden. Wir können alles verhandeln. Homo-Ehe, Militärabschaffung, alles, was konservativ ist, können wir über alles reden. Kein Problem. Hier sind die Beweise. Ich habe schon 15 konservative Themen mit einem Federstrich beerdigt. Du kannst Merkel nicht vorwerfen, oder ich tue es natürlich trotzdem, aber du kannst Merkel nicht vorwerfen, dass sie politisch ungeschickt agiert dadurch, dass sie keine verwundbaren Punkte hat, weil sie alles aufgeben würde. Jemand, der alles aufgeben würde, jemand, der alles verkaufen würde, jemand, der alles verhandeln würde, wenn das richtige Angebot gemacht wird, der ist praktisch nicht verwundbar. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Punkt, da muss man anfangen zu überlegen, bis zu welchem Punkt ist das Machtgeschick und ab welchem Punkt, und das ist dann wieder diese Obama-Frage, leg dich dein eigenes Machtgeschick aufs Kreuz, weil du dich nach und nach von allen Punkten verabschiedest, um nicht verwundbar zu sein und hinter bleibt nichts mehr übrig und du hast keine Überzeugung mehr. Du hast nichts mehr, wofür du gekämpft hast, außer der eigenen Macht, die dann so der letzte Rückzugsgefecht ist.
Und dieses Phänomen sehen wir eigentlich überall, außer in Ländern, wo, sagen wir mal so wie Ungarn oder so, wo dann Leute an die Macht kommen, die genau diese Aushöhlung der Politik, also diese Entleerung, und was Fefe mit der Adenauerzeit beschreibt, ist ja durchaus ein valides Gefühl, dass es damals noch um Themen ging. Wie auch immer, das Falsche war, aber tatsächlich ist dieses manifeste Gefühl, damals ging es noch um, was da ging es für, gegen irgendwas, da war es nicht beliebig und austauschbar.
Also ich finde, wir haben auch heute wichtige Themen. So Sachen wie, ob wir jetzt mal CO2-Emissionen runterkriegen oder hier die Energiebremse.
Aber das ist alles extrem abstrakt. Also damals war das...
Weißt du, damals ging es darum, irgendwie Lebensmittelmarken abschaffen oder nicht. So, das ist unmittelbar. Damals ging es darum, mehr Häuser bauen oder nicht mehr Häuser bauen. Unmittelbar.
Das stimmt, aber es gibt noch eine Grundierung, mit der ich mich dann ein bisschen intensiver beschäftigt habe. Nicht im Adenauer-Kontext, sondern im globalpolitischen Kontext. Und das ist natürlich, dass dieses über weite Strecken auch inszenatorisch sehr wirkungsvoll aufgeladene Gleichgewicht des Schreckens, also der Kampf der Supermächte gegeneinander, dieses Ostblock und Westblock-Phänomen, dass das etwas sehr Festigendes und Motivierendes hatte. Ja, war klar.
Der Tag hat eine Struktur, also dann herabzeiten wir die.
Ist schön zusammengefasst. Aber natürlich ist mit diesem Wegfall von diesem natürlichen Ying und Yang Prinzip, mit diesem Wegfall 1989 und Folgejahre, ist auch ein bisschen Sinn weggefallen. Und das Spannende ist, dass wir, totaler Riss schwenkt aber eigentlich genau das Thema, dass wir die Radikaleskalation der Überwachungsmaschinerie, die lässt sich zum Teil, aus meiner Meinung nach, es ist hier eine Meinung, nicht ein Faktum, darauf zurückführen, dass der natürliche Feind nicht mehr da war. Das heißt, du hattest nicht eine Adresse, wo du deine Kraft drauf geweicht hast, sondern du hast angefangen, überall zu suchen. Wo gibt es denn mögliche neue Feinde? Wir müssen jetzt überall gucken. Wir müssen wirklich überall gucken, weil ganz klar war, nicht hinter allem stecken die Russen, wie es lange Zeit narrativ war in den Vereinigten Ländern. Egal was, McAfee hat ja einfach gesagt, er steht in den Russen hinter, der ist von den Russen gekauft, der ist von den Russen gekauft, der ist von den Russen gekauft, der ist von den Russen gekauft, sondern auf einmal wusstest du nicht mehr, wer der Feind ist und du musstest ihn suchen. Diese Suchbewegung, die kann man durchaus wörtlich nehmen, die hat einfach dazu geführt, dass du so mit deinen ganzen vernetzten Ärmchen über die ganze Welt versuchst zu finden, wo ist denn da was? Dass das allein schon von der Metaphorik zeigt, wie sich diese Überwachungsmaschinerien ausgebreitet haben, da sehe ich einen Zusammenhang. Ich kann den nicht beweisen, weil er sich auch auf so einer überordneten Ebene stattfindet.
Es gibt da schon durchaus Hinweise drauf, einfach weil die Infrastruktur war ja da, die Budgets waren da und die haben ja auch hart herumgekämpft bis 2001, dass sie ihre Budgets irgendwie wieder bekamen. Also das war ja tatsächlich, wenn wir unter unserer Diskussion so denken, so 2001, 2002, 2003 war eigentlich auch dieses Narrativ, das irgendwie 9-11 im Wesentlichen stattgefunden hat, weil die Geheimnisse ihre Budgets bewahren wollten. Diese Theorie war ja quasi allgemein platz. Also kam ja jeder so ein bisschen auf die Idee, das ist ja doch ein bisschen fischies Ei, dass jetzt plötzlich die...
Ich glaube, ich glaube das nicht, weil ich da überzeugt bin, anders als ihr wahrscheinlich...
Bist du denn hier für ein Establishment-Vertreter?
Nein, ich versuche, ich bin der Natur skeptisch gegenüber der Gesamtsituation. Und was ich mir tatsächlich in dem Kontext vorstellen kann, ist, dass man an bestimmten Ecken und Enden weggeguckt hat und da bestimmte Sachen nicht gemacht hat. Ich glaube nicht, dass das ein Auftrag ist. Ich glaube, dass das ziemlich genau so geschehen, bis auf irgendwelche Details, die mich aber auch da nicht so interessieren, wie man den traditionellen und herkömmlichen Medien entnehmen kann. Dass da fishy Anteile dabei waren, ist auch klar. Dass das vielleicht nie ganz ans Tageslicht kommt, ist auch klar. Aber der für mich entscheidende Punkt ist viel eher, dass es nicht einen zwingenden Zusammenhang geben muss zwischen wir haben das Inside-Job und der Benutzung als Begründung für die Aufrüstung. Weil der zweite Teil reicht für sich genommen schon. Den ersten, da haben wir offensichtlich für mich etwas überraschend, aber unterschiedliche Auffassungen. Aber der zweite Teil ist für mich der Relevante. Mir ist völlig egal, ganz böse gesagt, wie 9-11 zustande gekommen ist. Für mich ist wichtig, dass das instrumentalisiert wurde von Minute 2 an und dass es extrem erfolgreich instrumentalisiert wurde, um eine Ideologie der Totalüberwachung durchzusetzen. Und zwar angefangen von Gesetzen über die Technologie dahinter bis hin zu den Strategien in den Administrationen.
Also der Punkt dabei ist...
Du sollst gleich sagen, wir haben jetzt in 33 Sendungen 9-11 nicht einmal erwähnt und das war Absicht. Und jetzt haben wir es einmal.
Ich hab's nicht getan. Ich hab das nicht erwähnt.
Also der interessante Punkt für mich dabei ist ja, ist eigentlich auch weniger, wie es tatsächlich denn dazu kam. Also ich denke, dass die Theorie, dass es halt strategisches Wegsehen und gut vorbereitet sein, auf das irgendwas passiert, die Wahrscheinlichkeit relativ hoch ist dafür, sodass man halt einfach bestimmte Themenfälle halt außen vor gelassen hat.
Ihr könnt ja mal eine Truffa-Sendung machen, das würde ja passen.
Hab ich keine Lust drauf. Letztendlich ist es auch wirklich egal, weil die Folgen sind halt das eigentlich Interessante. Und was mich dabei eigentlich interessiert ist aber eben genau diese politische Strategie des Vorbereitetseins auf ein Ereignis. Und das hat tatsächlich gerade mit rechter Sicherheits- und Überwachungspolitik ist es ja sehr frequent. Und die sagen es ja teilweise auch sehr offen. Also wenn du mit den Investitionsleuten oder mit den PKA-Lern redest, hast du häufiger so ein Ding so Ja, wir müssen jetzt mal ein bisschen was machen, weil sie wollen ja auch nicht, dass wenn beim nächsten Mal was passiert, wir dann halt die große Akte aus der Schublade holen.
Da würde ich gleich Einspruch einlegen, denn es geht nicht darum vorbereitet zu sein, sondern es geht darum Vorbereitungen zu treffen, damit am Ende die Schuldfrage geklärt ist und nicht bei mir hängen bleibt. Bei fast allen von diesen Sachen, wo jemand mal genau geguckt hat, diese Jodtabletten, Schweinegrippe, da ist von Anfang an völlig klar, dass die konkreten Maßnahmen bei weitem nicht reichen, wenn tatsächlich irgendwas passiert.
Nein, es geht nicht um die Maßnahmen, die wirklich was tun.
Das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen zu fahrart.
Sondern es geht um die Verschärfung der Gesetze hinterher.
Genau, das ist der Punkt, auf den ich euch auch in Ordnung frage.
Also die Frage ist ja, was hast du in der Schublade liegen, wenn der nächste Terroranschlag passiert? Und da sind die halt super vorbereitet. Und das ist ja auch tatsächlich so ein Politikstil, zu sagen, wir müssen die Ereignisse nicht wirklich kontrollieren. Das wird schon was passieren, wenn wir strategisch ein paar Felder nicht so genau hingucken, kein Geld reintun oder die Dinge einfach so passieren.
Ich versuch das doch mal, um den sofort strittigen Teil zu bereinigen. Der nicht strittige reicht schon aus. Da werden wir auch, glaube ich, nicht übereinkommen, weil ich da im Zweifel sehr, sehr viel weniger verschwörungstheoretisch unterwegs bin als ihr einfach aus einem Prinzip heraus. Aber der Punkt, auf den ich hinaus möchte, ist, wo wir uns sofort einigen können, ist, dass es Leute gibt, die Konzepte geschrieben haben für den Fall X und für den Fall Y und für den Fall Z. Und diese Konzepte kommen dann relativ schnell auf den Tisch. Die sind noch nicht mal wahnsinnig ausgefeilt. Die ergeben sich auch sehr stark situativ. Dann kommt halt irgendwie, ich würde jetzt nicht von Attentat sprechen, weil es irgendwie gleich so das Allergrößte ist. Aber das reicht ja schon, wenn man das so in dem Fall, wo konnte man das nachvollziehen, als in den 90er Jahren mal diese Kampfhund-Debatte stattfand. Da ging es hin und her und rauf und runter. Und dann gab es einen wirklich total Horror-Fall, wo so ein Kind angefallen wurde von einem Kampfhund. Und dann haben die Leute, die schon die Konzepte in den Taschen hatten, was man jetzt genau zu tun hatte, Minuten gebraucht, um diese Konzepte auch sowohl PR-mäßig, wie auch politisch einzupflegen in die Landschaft. Und in einer Geschwindigkeit, wo vollkommen klar war, das war in der Tasche. Und ich glaube erst mal, lasst uns mal die Wirken darauf hin, Teil einfach stecken und lasst uns mal darauf konzentrieren, wie man mit Ereignissen klug Politik macht. Und zwar erstmal wertneutrale Ereignisse. Dass also der Staudamm bricht und dann hast du ein Konzept in der Tasche, wie du Wasserkraft morgen abschaffen kannst. Und das kommst du zum richtigen Zeitpunkt. Und dann kannst du auch immer sagen, ich hab's schon immer gesagt, der Staudamm ist gebrochen, Wasserkraft ist viel gefährlicher als Atomkraft. Ich hab übrigens hier ein Atomkraftwerk in der Tasche. Also dass diese Mechanik, dass die zum politischen Geschäft dazugehört, vorbereitet zu sein und im richtigen Moment, mit dem richtigen Timing so eine orchestrierte Aktion zu starten. PR, ein Gesetzesentwurf, zwei politische Nasen zu haben, mit dem man schon lang zu tun hat und die einem dann gefallen tun und die ein paar Stichworte droppen.
Genau das ist ja tatsächlich in Ungarn noch passiert. Dass die in der Abfolge von solchen Ereignissen, in dem Fall wissen wir zum Teil, dass sie kreiert wurden oder dass ihnen das so passiert sind. Dass das also genau dieses Generieren, das was ich mal das momentan anvisierte Feindbild genannt habe, damit man einen schönen Begriff dafür hat, also sozusagen die Sau, die sich draufgetrieben wird, dass man da einfach Optionen hat. Es gibt halt immer so eine Abfolge, so wie Nazis, Kinder, Porno, Terroristen. So ist halt so immer so die durchroutierende Trinitiv und Feindbilder und dann kommt ab und zu nochmal was dazu. Jetzt haben wir irgendwie noch vielleicht noch Ebola oder so. Letzten Endes ist der Trend der Maßnahmen, die du versuchst, mit diesen Events durchzuziehen. Den legst du ja vorher fest und das sind ja politische Grundüberzeugungen.
Also ich seh ehrlich gesagt weniger Verschwörungstheoretisch als ihr, weil ich denke einfach, es kommt zu einer Debatte über ein normales irgendwie BKA-Gesetz und dann gibt's den Vorschlag, so den NPD-Vorschlag, so wir müssen hier Lager einrichten, keine Ahnung, ja und der wird sofort von allen irgendwie vom Tisch genommen und wenn dann irgendwas passiert, greift man halt zum nächsten in der Sortierung nach Schlimmheit, je nachdem, wie übel der Sache ist, wie passiert ist. Die Sachen sind nicht erarbeitet, damit man was rumliegen kann, also in Einzelfällen mag das vielleicht so sein, aber im Allgemeinen liegen da Gesetze rum, die so auch schon mal diskutiert worden sind und nicht Sachen, die man sich für irgendwie, wenn das nächste Mal ein Damm bricht, zurückgelegt hat.
Ich glaube, es gibt beides.
Es wird sicher in Einzelfällen beides geben, ja.
Damm ist insofern ein falsches Beispiel, weil wir ursprünglich ausgegangen sind von der Sicherheits- und Überwachungspolitik, wo es tatsächlich so ist.
Da gibt es eine andere Dynamik, die ich an der Stelle mal ansprechen möchte, nämlich die, dass du als Politiker nie ein Risiko trägst, wenn du Sachen mehr sicher machst. Aber du trägst immer ein Risiko, wenn du sie nicht sicherer gemacht hast und dann ist was passiert.
Sicherheit ist da ja eine Einbahnstraße.
Deswegen ist das eine Einbahnstraße, die von sich aus immer nur in eine Richtung gehen kann und jeder Politiker hat Druck, ein bisschen in die Richtung zu gehen, ob das gerade Sinn macht oder nicht, damit wenn was passiert, der sagen kann, aber wir haben noch was gemacht.
Na ja, ist Sicherheit wirklich eine Einbahnstraße? Ich glaube, dass es nämlich eigentlich nicht so ist.
Nee, aber ich glaube, es ist eine argumentatorische Einbahnstraße. Ich glaube nicht, dass es eine faktische ist.
Genau, weil sonst hätten wir nämlich deutlich mehr Erhöhung des Polizeietags für Personal. Und de facto ist es aber so, dass eben öffentlich sagen sie halt immer, wir brauchen mehr Sicherheit, Sicherheit, Sicherheit. Und de facto wären die Etats für Personal bei der Polizei, die zu mehr Sicherheit führen würde, werden die immer weiter abgebaut und reduziert.
Oder wir haben, was auch ein bekanntes Muster ist, es gibt ja sowas wie eine politische Inflation. Ich versuche das mal ein bisschen zu umschreiben. Gerade der Sicherheitsbereich hat in den letzten 20 Jahren halt wahnsinnig zugenommen, weil das digitale Feld dazugekommen ist. Wenn du also bloß nichts machst, dann wird sich das dramatisch reduzieren. Und sogar, du kannst sogar neues Geld reinstecken und es wird trotzdem unsicherer, weil halt mehr abgedeckt werden muss, weil ein neues Feld dazukommt. Und das wiederum bedeutet, dass du eigentlich ständig hinterherfüttern musst und mehr Geld reinpumpen müsstest, damit es nur so bleibt, wie es im Moment schon ist. Das wahnsinnig hohe...
Nee, das halte ich für... Nee, das kann ich tatsächlich nicht bestätigen, weil letztendlich ist es so, dass die... Es ist ja nicht so, dass das Internet oder der digitale Bereich dazu führt, dass es mehr Kriminalität gibt.
Nee, aber du brauchst mehr Kräfte mit mehr Know-how.
Nee, du brauchst nicht mehr, du brauchst sie nur woanders, weil...
Aber wo fällt es dann weg?
Na, zum Beispiel für die Diebstähle sind zum Beispiel seit vielen Jahren rückläufig.
Also wir sehen ja, dass eine Menge Dinge sich verlagern. Also du hast zum Beispiel den gesamten Bereich irgendwie der Videokopierkriminalität, den gibt es halt nicht mehr. Du hast den, der gesamte Bereich Autodiebstahl ist drastisch gefallen, seit sie irgendwie Technologie da eingeführt haben.
So drastisch jetzt auch nicht. Also der ist ja immer noch vorhanden und...
Ja, je nachdem wie die Technologiewellen gerade laufen, aber trotzdem fällt das...
Vielleicht können wir uns darauf einigen, dass man dafür qualifizierte Reser-Kräfte braucht. Und qualifizierte heißt teurer und teurer ist mehr Mittel. Also was die Kostensituation angeht, stimmt es auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass hier weil jetzt Internetkriminalität da ist, es auf einmal weniger Autokriminalität gibt. Also das ist nur nebenbei.
Das glaube ich schon. Weil die...
Also letztendlich ist es so, das kann man es tatsächlich sehen in den Statistiken.
Da kenne ich mich zu wenig aus. So Mord, Diebstahl, Einbruch. Da kenne ich mich jetzt gar nicht.
Das ist überhaupt zu wenig aus. Du liest doch nicht die BKA-Statistiken. Die sind auch schon spannend.
Die sind echt spannend. Also die BKA-Statistiken sind insofern interessant, weil sie, wenn man was der Zierke so erzählt...
Wenn man das mal gegencheckt mit seinen eigenen Statistiken....
mit den eigenen Statistiken mal dagegen hält, dann sieht man, dass der nicht umsonst die Strategie wählt, nur mit Anekdoten zu argumentieren. Der argumentiert ja niemals mit Statistiken. Das würde ihm nie in den Sinn kommen, mit einer Statistik, die irgendwie einigermaßen solid ist, zu argumentieren. Es sei denn, es gibt mal gerade einen ausgewählten Spike irgendwo, den er benutzen kann. Aber mit großflächiger Kriminalstatistik zu argumentieren, wirst du sie nie bei erwischen.
Ziergäste jetzt auch Geschichte zum Glück.
Aber trotzdem ist diese Strategie, immer nur mit emotional aufgeladenen Einzelfallgeschichten zu argumentieren, die hat ja Methode. Weil es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass aus verschiedensten Gründen unter anderem auch insgesamt leicht gestiegener Wohlstand für verschiedene Kriminalitätsformen einfach rückläufig sind. Und wie wir wissen, hat das teilweise nicht mal mit der Sicherheitspolitik zu tun. Wir wissen zum Beispiel, dass die Mordrate in den USA seit dem Verbot von verbleiten Benzin und verbleiten Farben drastisch runtergegangen ist. Und zwar ist eine Korrelation, die ist so dramatisch, dass man sie quasi als Textbookbeispiel für ernsthafte Korrelation verwenden kann. Und mit Sicherheitspolitik hat nicht mit der Anzahl der Polizisten zu tun, sondern einfach nur damit, dass weniger Leute wahnsinnig sind.
Die, die, die, dass das jetzt auch nur transportiertes Wissen von dem ich nicht sagen kann, ob es stimmt oder nicht. Ich hab...
Ist das nicht immer so?
Manchmal nicht. In ganz seltenen Ausnahmefällen nicht. Ich hab eben gelesen, dass die Abtreibungspolitik, ich glaube, das ist in dem Buch Freakonomics, die Abtreibungspolitik ziemlich maßgeblich damit zu tun hatte, wie die Kriminalität und die Mordrate miteinander zusammenhängt. Aber wir gehen so ein bisschen weg von dem eigentlichen Punkt.
Nee, der eigentliche Punkt ist ja durchaus, dass eben die Wirksamkeit von Maßnahmen in der Politik, also diese Illusion, dass der Politiker einen deterministischen Hebel hat, mit dem er Gesellschaft beeinflussen kann.
Das ist ein Narrativ, wo übrigens wir alle, auch wir, die drei beteiligt sind und daran festhalten, das ist halt so ein bisschen...
Aus eigenem Nutz, wenn ich das mal erklären darf, denn sonst kann ich dem Politiker keine Schuld geben.
Ja, mein Freund und Kompagnon Christoph Kappes. Regelmäßig trollt er so ein bisschen sanft rum in verschiedenen Medien und auch privat manchmal mich. Ein Punkt, mit dem er sehr oft einen Nerv trifft, von dem ich weiß, dass da irgendwas dahinter ist, weil er mich so stört, ist, dass er sagt, wieso geht er eigentlich davon alle aus, dass das ein Problem ist, was ein Politiker überhaupt lösen kann. Wieso ist eure Standard-Annahme, wir haben Problem X und da kann eine Politik Y dagegen tun und dann geht es weg. Und leider hat er ein bisschen recht. Es gibt bestimmte Systeme, und ich glaube, die Gesellschaft gehört dazu, die einfach so komplex und so vielschichtig sind und auch von so komplizierten Kausalitätsmustern durchdrungen, dass du eigentlich fast nur noch so Symbolpolitik machen kannst und hoffen kannst, dass die wenigstens nicht kontraproduktiv ist aus Versehen. Und ich fürchte, man darf da nicht zu tief sich rein. Wenn man sich da zu tief reinbohrt, dann kann man auf einmal Merkel total gut verstehen. Wie willst du deine Überzeugung behalten, wenn du sagst, ich weiß eh nicht, wie was funktioniert. Ich drücke hier drauf, weil ich denke, das ist gut. Und dann erhöhen wir irgendwie die ganzen Renten und dann werden auf einmal irgendwie die Arbeitnehmer arbeitslos. Man weiß ja nicht, was passiert. Man weiß so wahnsinnig wenig, wie, wo was passiert. Und zu einem bestimmten Punkt weigere ich mich auch, zu sagen, das ist so. Ein bisschen ist es auch von mir auch eine Zuschreibung. Das muss aber ein Problem sein, was die Politik lösen kann. Einfach, um nicht zu verzweifeln. Einfach, um noch so eine Restüberzeugung zu behalten.
Das kommt daher, dass wir die Politik genau dafür haben, dass sie unsere Probleme löst. Und wenn wir jetzt postulieren, die können das gar nicht.
Die können es halt nicht immer.
Genau, der Punkt ist halt durchaus, dass wir uns häufig in Politikfelder bewegen und uns für Politikfelder interessieren, die genuin Politik gemacht sind. Geheimdienste zum Beispiel oder Überwachungen sind halt Dinge, die Bestandteil des Systems Politik an sich sind. Also die jetzt nur einen sehr marginalen Realweltanteil haben, sondern die halt primär im Binnenverhältnis des Systems Politik verortet sind.
Da könnte man jetzt philosophisch sehr, sehr hart darüber diskutieren. Weil ich glaube, die haben eine ganz tiefe Verwurzeltheit im System Politik. Die sind nicht künstlich, sondern die sind...
Nee, aber die sind Bestandteile. Also die sind halt sehr inhärent in diesem System.
Genau. Und zwar aus Kontrollgründen.
Genau. Aber deswegen sind es eben Themen, also sagen wir mal Überwachungspolitik, Sicherheitspolitik und so, sind halt, also Sicherheitspolitik und zum Teil Überwachungspolitik in jedem Fall, sind Themen, wo wir ein relativ gutes Gefühl dafür zu haben glauben, dass die auch politisch zu ändern sind.
Wir kommen wieder an dieses Obama-Problem. Also angenommen jetzt übermorgen wird ein Kanzler der Grünen gewählt. Ich wollte nicht von den Linken sagen, weil das ist noch unwahrscheinlich.
Hör mal auf, die Linken machen jetzt in Thüringen demnächst die Regierung, hab ich gehört. Schaffen die dann das Landesamt für Verfassungsschutz ab? Das wäre doch mal eine Frage.
Null. Ich glaube, das ist doch genau. Warum eigentlich nicht?
Die sind doch die Opfer.
Nein, ich glaube, sie können es nicht. Zum einen, weil solche Systeme, solche Behörden sehr gut da drin sind, Abwehrstrategien zu fahren.
Das ist aber schon passiert. In Berlin zum Beispiel gab es tatsächlich die Situation, dass das Landesamt für Verfassungsschutz war hier so verkorkt, dass die alle rausgeschmissen haben. Also alle, sind alle gegangen, inklusive der Amtsführung. Dann haben sie eine neue Präsidentin eingesetzt und die durften sich neu auf ihre alten Arbeitsplätze bewerben und dann wurden sie angeguckt, ob man sie haben wollte oder nicht. Also es geht.
Wie viel Prozent sind genommen worden? Weißt du das?
Ich glaube, die haben tatsächlich mehr als die Hälfte ausgetauscht bei der Gelegenheit.
Das wäre für mich, ich kenne diesen Fall nicht.
Also müssen wir nochmal nachgucken, was die genaue Quote war. Aber da war ich auch sehr erstaunt, als ich das tatsächlich hörte. Aber es geht offensichtlich, dass man sowas tun kann.
Okay, das ist für mich ein, ich weiß nicht, ob ein positives Signal.
Ein Fanal der Hoffnung.
Ja, ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob es tatsächlich ein Fanal der Hoffnung ist. Da würde ich nämlich warten, bis ich diese Quote höre. Also alles unter 50 Prozent für die gleichen Leute wieder eingestellt, würde ich eher als Fanal der Hoffnung bezeichnen. Und alles über 50 Prozent würde ich eher als Kosmetik betrachten, tatsächlich. Deswegen werde das wäre, also auch, wir gucken es nach.
Wir gucken es nach, aber ich meine, wieso würde es den Hausmeister austauschen? Es gibt da schon auch Leute, wo man sagen kann, okay, aber eine Sache möchte ich hier nicht unwidersprochen stehen lassen, nämlich diese Idee, dass das alles so furchtbar komplex ist, dass man es eh nicht verstehen oder gar erwarten kann. Nicht alles. Ich möchte kurz begründen, warum ich das nicht stehen lassen kann, weil das nämlich einer der zentralen Instrumente von Merkels Politik ist und überhaupt von Politik in der Neuzeit, dass der Bevölkerung im Grunde nicht mehr gesagt wird, was wir jetzt konkret tun, sondern dass es alles so komplex ist, dass wir das schon im Griff haben und ihr müsst euch da mal nicht so kümmern. Und das ist auch tatsächlich zu einer Strategie geworden, wie man die Opposition daran hindert, gegen Gesetz zu opponieren, indem man einfach sagt, hör mal zu, das Ganze ist jetzt so komplex, dass um den Punkt auch nur auszuführen, gegen den du opponieren möchtest, brauchst du mehr als die zehn Sekunden, die du hier als Soundbite hast. Also dieses Komplexitätsargument finde ich eine der gefährlichsten Sachen, die es in der Politik überhaupt gibt.
Das finde ich nicht, wenn man das bewusst benutzt. Also ich finde erstmal legitim zu sagen, dass Gesellschaft als System unfassbar komplex ist, weil das ist meiner Meinung nach eine praktisch unverrückbare Wahrheit. Der zweite Punkt, den ich aber dazu formulieren würde, wäre, du bist als Ideologe und ich glaube, Politiker sind fast alle Ideologen, also Leute, die eine Aktion auf eine Überzeugung beruhen, für richtig halten, dass du gezwungen bist, bestimmte Teilbereiche zu vereinfachen. Also einfach zu sagen, das ist zwar komplex, aber wir machen das jetzt trotzdem auf die Art A oder B oder C. Und diese Vereinfachungsgeschichte, die führt eigentlich dazu, dass du anfängst, ein bisschen unfair zu werden. Wenn du sagst, okay, wir müssen jetzt die Pendler entlasten, wir machen jetzt Maßnahme A. Und dann musst du dir alles ein bisschen so zurechtbiegen, obwohl es viel komplexer ist und viel anstrengend, wenn du überhaupt nicht weißt, ob es funktioniert. Du musst es dir so ein bisschen zurechtbiegen, dass am Ende tatsächlich das rauskommt, was du eigentlich möchtest. Diese Art von Vereinfachung ist, glaube ich, wichtig für die Politikvermittlung, für die Politik selbst und auch für die eigene Überzeugung. Ich habe das bei mir übrigens bemerkt, das ist ein völlig anderes Thema, aber für mich auch nochmal ein echt schwieriges. Ich habe versucht, mich selbst zu fragen, ob ich für einen Militäreinsatz wäre gegen den islamischen Staat, gegen IS, also in Nordirage und Syrien. Der ganze Komplex politisch habe ich davon wahnsinnig wenig Ahnung. Ich kann also nicht sagen, dass diese Fraktion, die kämpft mit denen, und den wir von Iran unterstützt und der von Saudi-Arabien, und die sind schon seit vielen Jahrtausenden verfallen, weiß ich alles nicht, kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Ich habe da mit Leuten drüber gesprochen, die mir gesagt haben, es ist noch auf andere Art anders, als du glaubst, dass es anders ist. Eigentlich auch mal ganz interessant, aber dann sehe ich so ein Video, wo wirklich irgendwie so ein Vollidiot, und ich muss es vorher ausmachen, weil ich es nicht er trage, jemandem den Kopf abschneidet. Und ich merke in dem Moment, wie diese Instrumentalisierung, diese beabsichtige Instrumentalisierung, dann bei mir funktioniert. Und in der Sekunde, wo ich dieses Video sehe, wo ich vorher dachte, na ja, ich finde jetzt einen Militäreinsatz nicht gut, in der Sekunde, wo ich dieses Video sehe, muss ich ja nicht mal zu Ende sehen. Ich muss nur lesen, was da passiert. Setze bei mir so einen Nachdenkprozess ein, wo ich schon weiß, wo er hinführt. Nämlich, wo du denkst, na ja, da wird offensichtlich eine Grenze überschritten, die so krass ist, dass ich nicht mehr voll überzeugt bin, ob es nicht doch richtig ist, da jetzt mal ein militärisches Eingreifen.
Na ja, letztendlich ist es ja wie immer die Manipulation durch Emotionen an so einer Stelle. Also das sind emotionale...
Aber es ist deswegen falsch. Das ist ja auch noch mal eine Frage.
Das ist eine berechtigte Frage. Also ich meine, wir haben diese Diskussion ja in den 90ern am Jugoslawienkrieg halt sehr intensiv und länglich geführt. Und letztendlich ist halt die Frage, ob du eben die Zirke nummer machst, also halt irgendwie mit emotionalen Einzelgeschichten Politik machst, was ja durchaus ein Politikstil ist, den man fahren kann. Das geht ja, oder ob du sagst, du hast halt irgendwie eher eine, sag mal, rational-wissenschaftlichen Politikstil und versuchst halt Dinge aus Erfahrung zu lernen, daraus zu schließen, was du weißt, was irgendwie an deiner Faktenbasis ist und möglicherweise auch ein bisschen langfristiger zu denken. Nicht nur irgendwie, wir müssen diesen Typen, der jetzt da gerade diesen armen Journalisten geköpft hat, den müssen wir jetzt unbedingt erschießen.
Das ist zwar richtig, aber auf der anderen Seite neigt ja auch ein System eher dazu, nicht überhitzt hyperemotional zu sein, sondern Systeme insgesamt in ihren Alltagsfunktionen, nicht in ihren Spikes hast du es vorgenannt, in ihren Alltagsfunktionen neigen die eher dazu, zu rational zu sein und zu kalt und zu kühl und dann zu sagen, du hast gerade eine schwere Zeit, aber hier ist dein Hartz IV und du kriegst keinen Cent mehr, weil es steht hier im Gesetz. Also diese Kälte, diese hyperrationale Kälte des Systems ist für mich in der Fläche ein größeres Problem als einzelne emotionale Spikes.
Naja, also mein Problem dabei ist halt eher, wenn wir mal kurz an den schönen Filmen Wake the Dog zurückdenken, dass die Benutzung von solchen emotionalen Ereignissen zu bewusst passiert. Weil das zu verlässlich funktioniert. Zu verlässlich. Das ist halt so eine Nummer, die wird halt dieser Art der Manipulation zu routiniert. Also es ist halt mittlerweile, wenn man Fox News guckt zum Beispiel. Gelegentlich höfreich mal zehn Minuten Fox News Nachrichten zu gucken, nur um sich mal wieder sozusagen die Realität an dieser Stelle kurz einzublenden, danach schnell wieder auszublenden und so zu machen. Und was da passiert, ist eigentlich exakt genau das. Da wird halt eben genau nur argumentiert auf einer emotionalen Ebene, aber in einer Art und Weise routiniert instrumentalisiert für sehr durchsichtige Sachen, dass einem echt schlecht davon wird. Du kannst dich diesen emotionalen Bildern nicht verschließen, natürlich nicht. Und du merkst einfach, wie du gerade manipuliert wirst.
Und das funktioniert aber manchmal trotzdem. Natürlich ist auch, nehmen wir wieder den islamischen Start und seine Kopfabschneide-Videos, übrigens noch ein ganz eigenes Phänomen, dass eine terrororganisation Social Media so präzise für die eigene Inszenierung benutzt und es dann auch noch klappt. Weil irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gelesen habt, weltweit reisen Teenager, Jungs wie Mädchen völlig absurderweise nach Syrien und in den Irak, um sich da dem islamischen Start anzuschließen.
Ich finde es nicht sehr absurd.
Ich finde es nicht nur nicht absurd. Ich bin auch sehr zurückhaltend mit den Storys von diesen beiden österreichischen Mädchen, die gemerkt haben, dass es genau so emotionale Manipulationen wie was der Staat macht.
Das ist ja richtig, aber es funktioniert da trotzdem auf einer bestimmten Ebene. Funktioniert es ja und man kann es auch nachvollziehen. Es kommt ja nicht jetzt irgendwie ein Berliner Rapper da zufällig hin, sondern es hat für eine bestimmte Klientel eine große Anziehungskraft und die wird es über die sozialen Medien vermittelt und die wird übrigens über die traditionellen Medien gespiegelt. Der islamische Staat macht da und das wollte ich mal was zu überschreiben, aber ich muss da noch ein bisschen tiefer eindringen in die Materie. Die haben eine PR-Strategie, eine Propagandastrategie, die über die sozialen Medien ihren Ausgangspunkt nimmt und dann von den traditionellen Medien gespiegelt und verstärkt wird, einfach dadurch, dass traditionelle Medien, egal was sie schreiben, in bestimmten Kreisen einfach als krasses Feindbild betrachtet werden. Und das bedeutet, die haben so eine doppelte Instrumentalisierung am Start. Und das finde ich fast schon erstaunlich.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, hast du diese Geschichte gelesen, gerade im Spiel bei Spiegel Online, dieses Interview hatten mit diesem türkischen IS-Rekrute? Es wäre es tatsächlich mal mit der feinen Lupe zu lesen, auch besonders sollte man diese kursiv eingesetzten Spiegel-Online-Erklärungsversuche da einfach ausblenden, die kann man einfach überspringen. Aber was der sagt, ist sehr interessant, weil die Strategie da, also die Propagandastrategie, beruht halt auf dem exakten Gegenteil von dem, was Merkel tut. Und zwar ist es ein Werte-Fundamentalismus, und zwar im Detail, in der Umsetzung nicht stimmt, aber in der Propagandamesage.
Werte über alles.
Sagen sie halt, wir haben nur einen einzigen Wert, und das ist der Koran. Alles andere interessiert uns nicht. Wir haben keine, wir differenzieren nicht mehr, für uns ist es nicht mehr komplex. Wir haben keine Notwendigkeit mehr, jetzt da irgendwie lange über irgendwelche Dinge zu diskutieren. Wir müssen uns auch nicht rechtfertigen. Wir müssen uns nicht rechtfertigen für Kompromisse, die wir machen, für Dinge, wo wir möglicherweise gerade mal irgendwie Dinge irgendwie anders machen mussten, als im Koran steht, weil wir haben ein Ziel. Wir haben ein Endziel, und dieses Endziel ist klar das weltweite Kalifat, und wir müssen da keine großartigen, gedanklichen Leistungen jetzt mehr vollbringen, sondern wir haben einfache Rechtfertigung, wir haben nämlich ein Ziel. Diese simple Radikalität, dass die gerade für eine Generation, die mit dieser ganzen Komplexität und diesen Kompromissen und dieser Politik, die halt einfach keine Ziele, keine Werte, keine irgendwie gearteten Normen für ihr eigenes Handeln hat.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass der Charme der Einfachheit auch funktioniert, wenn die Einfachheit eigentlich eine extremistische Ausprägung hat, und zwar auch eine offenextremistische.
Du willst einfach das Gefühl haben, wenn du dich irgendwo einbringst, dass es was bringt. Und das wird ja zumindest in Westeuropa der Jugend systematisch ausgetrieben. Dieser Gedanke, ich kann was bewegen, sondern du kannst irgendwie bei den Jungen was weiß ich mit machen.
Ich meine die Selbstwuchsamkeit.
Ich glaube, es ist scheißegal, welches Ziel du vertrittst, solange du überhaupt ein klares Ziel hast, weil das einfach aus dieser Gemengelage von Merkel, Unklarheiten einfach die Leute... Ich komme mir langsam vor wie in den letzten Jahren von Kohl, wo es einfach frisch Volljährige Kinder gab, die noch nie was anderes als Kohl erlebt haben. Und das für nicht einen furchtbaren Gedanken. Und ich glaube, das ist mit der Merkel genauso, dass die Leute einfach keinen Bock mehr haben auf dieses... Ich finde das übrigens auch kein Begrüß, einen Vorwurf gegen die Merkel zu sagen, die ist opportunistisch, weil das ist genau, was ich von ihr erwarte.
Zum einen haben die Leute nicht die Schnauze voll von Merkel, sondern eigentlich genau im Gegenteil.
Nein, die Jugend hat die Schnauze voll von Merkel.
Aber die sind mir verboren geblieben.
Die sind nicht nur zu wenig?
Also vielleicht in deinem direkten Umfeld, aber die Quote der CDU-Wähler bei den jungen Leuten ist absurd hoch. Also die ist höher als sonst wann. Merkel wird sehr, sehr übergreifend gewählt. Also abfällig abgesehen davon, dass wir eine Zustimmungsquote haben von einem halben Jahrwandel, 59 Prozent. Also das sind Werte, die erstaunlich sind für jemanden, der schon 200 Jahre in der Macht ist. Also rein gefühlsmäßig.
Wie du gesagt hast, was ich vorhin sagte, die wird halt gewählt für Stabilität.
Eigentlich wird sie gewählt für die Abwesenheit von Politik.
Die Abwesenheit von Veränderung.
Die Abwesenheit von Politik. Merkel verwaltet da vor sich hin und ich hab da mit Frank Stürmacher mal lange drüber diskutiert, unter anderem deswegen, weil ich eigentlich vorhatte, für ihn einen Merkel-Artikel zu schreiben, wo die Entwicklung ihrer Digitalpolitik so ein bisschen als Aufhänger für ihren Stil benutzt wird. Sie hat so ein paar Ansatzpunkte, die man sehr spannend finden kann, wo man an ihrer Digitalpolitik, wie sie damit umgegangen ist, wen hat sie wann reden lassen. Da kann man viel dran ablesen. Und da hab ich mich zum ersten Mal sehr viel tiefer mit Merkel beschäftigt, versucht auch ein bisschen dahinter zu blicken, was da los ist. Und ich glaube, die Abwesenheit von dem, was eigentlich Politik ausmacht, die ist ein total großes Argument pro Merkel. Ich glaube, ganz viele Leute in Deutschland haben überhaupt keinen Bock auf Politik. Die wollen damit gar nicht so viel zu tun haben. Das ist eine Politik, der hat auch schon echt häufig zu ganz schlimmen Situationen geführt in Deutschland. Muss man ja vielleicht auch mal aus der Warte betrachten. Und dann ein frau gewordenes Versprechen an der Spitze des Staates zu haben, die sagt, ich verwalte das alles so hin. Aber diesen ganzen politischen Kram mit Ideologien und Überzeugungen, die das Ganze, wo Leute da vorne stehen und mit einer Fahne rumwedeln und in eine Richtung begeistert rennen, das wird es mit mir nicht geben, denn ich habe gar keine Überzeugung. Und jemand, der das so vermittelt und das auch so ankommt, bei in den Vorstädten, wo halt die Leute sind, die das Protosozialprodukt zusammenklöppeln, die genau das Gefühl haben, ob Merkel jetzt links oder rechts rumgeht, eins ist vollkommen klar, bei ihr werden wir niemals eine Überraschung erleben. In keine Richtung.
Na, außer so kleine wie Atomkraft.
Ich glaube ernsthaft, dass Merkel da ganz präzisem nach dem Merkel-Prinzip gehandelt hat. Ich glaube wirklich, dass er ist mit Fukushima die Volks-Säle, grauenvolles Wort, auch Volk ist ja kein schönes Wort, aber das ist quasi, das Merkel wird es vielleicht so nennen, aber das ist so das Mindset der Bevölkerung, der wahlberichtlichste Bevölkerung.
Die Bürgerinnen und Bürger würde Merkel sagen.
Ich glaube, die waren vorher gar nicht so stark gegen Atomkraft, wie man in den Umfragen halt immer versucht hat, rauszukritzeln und die haben wirklich erst mit Fukushima gesagt, oh jetzt müssen wir wirklich handeln. Und das hat Merkel so sensorisch gespürt und ich meine, nicht nur sensorisch, es ist ja vor ein paar Wochen diese Umfragen-Geschichten ja. Bekannt geworden, dass Merkel einfach alles per Umfragen regelt, was ich unfassbar spooky finde und auch übrigens unterskandalisiert in den Medien.
In der Tat.
Ich hab da über ihn geschrieben.
Na ja, man kann auch argumentieren, das ist genau was du erwartest von der Kanzlerin. Ich mein, die wird gewählt und die soll gefälligst tun, was die Bevölkerung haben will.
Das ist ihr Verständnis von Demokratie.
Und es ist vor allem ein Verständnis, was mehr als was Schröder von Politik hat. Also da möchte ich jetzt kurz einhaken.
Wenn du weißt, wie Umfragen gemacht werden kannst, dann gehst du nicht mit dem Quartier.
Das ist einfach umfragen.
Erreicht halt alte Leute, die noch eine Festnetznummer haben.
Du hast bis vor einigen Jahren einfach sogar noch nur Festnetz drin gehabt. Und auch heute wird das halt meistens noch, wenn man sich die Umfragen anguckt, über Faktoren gerechnet. Da wird ja die Repräsentativität nicht so erreicht, indem du wirklich von jeder Gruppe einen hast, sondern die Gesamtheit ist groß genug. Und dann guckt man, wie das gewichtet ist, und dann legt man irgendwelche Faktoren drauf, die das irgendwie Richtung treiben sollen. Und das ist eigentlich absurd. Das hat überhaupt nichts mehr mit ich schaue mal jetzt auf die Meinung der Bürger zu tun, sondern es ist wirklich nur noch so eine mediale Vermittlung der dritten Ableitung von irgendwas, was mal eine Meinung gewesen ist.
Ist das nicht sowieso immer Bullshit? Also überhaupt die Idee, dass du so was wie eine Umfrage machen kannst, wo du hast dann die Meinung? Die Meinung der Bevölkerung?
Das ist nicht ganz Bullshit, weil da wird halt viel Unfug getrieben.
Naja, das hängt auch komplett davon ab, was am Vorabend die Bildzeitung gedruckt hat, oder nicht?
Ja, interessanterweise gar nicht so stark. Aber letztlich ist diese Umfragefixierung eigentlich nur eine Folge, zum einen von Merkels herangehensweise, aber natürlich auch von der Betrachtung, der politischen Betrachtung, dass Wahlen gar nicht sich so dramatisch unterscheiden von einer Umfrage. Also eigentlich machen da Leute Kreuze auf dem Papier. Das ist so schon mal sachlich faktisch was Ähnliches. Und dann ist dieser Begriff die Abstimmung an der Urne, ja, darüber entscheiden die Leute an der Urne. Diese klassische Sonntagsfragen, die man immer so nach vorne stellt. Eigentlich ist es so eine Art Demokratie-Mimikrie, könnte man jedenfalls so betrachten. Und da, diese Fixierung da drauf, die hat natürlich auch irgendwie so was Kargokulthaftes.
Also ich glaube, dass das erst durch Obama so stark geworden ist, weil der hat es komplett digitalisiert vorangetrieben. Bei dem wird jedes Wort in jeder Rede durch diverse Fokusgruppen getragen.
Da Gegenspricht, dass Gerd Schröder auch ziemlich intensiv mit Umfragen gearbeitet hat.
Tatsächlich?
Ja, aber nicht mit den Papieren, sondern mit Gesprächen mit Leuten, die die Umfragen gemacht haben.
Vom Selbstverständnis her benutzen sie ja eigentlich sozusagen das beste Mittel, was sie kriegen können. Sie benutzen halt das, was da ist, um irgendwie den Volkswillen zu verwalten. Aber es gibt keinerlei, wie auch immer geartete Bestrebungen, das tatsächlich mal zu ermitteln. Es gab jetzt nur diesen zackhaften, gescheiterten Versuch mit der Piratenpartei und Liquid Democracy einen Schritt ins Internetzeitalter der Demokratie zu tun. Aber sowohl was Obama macht als auch was Merkel macht, sind ja eigentlich sozusagen verwaltete, midierte Wege des Erfassens dessen, was die Menschen wirklich wollen.
Eine Sache liegt mir noch auf dem Herzen. Wir haben jetzt mehrfach am Rande fallen lassen, dass das US-System noch kaputt als unseres ist. Aber an einigen Stellen sind die auch weiter als wir. Denn die haben bei ihren Gesetzen ein Ablaufdatum drin. Und das Gesetz zum Beispiel der Paint Redact nicht bei allen. Aber dieses Konzept gibt es wenigstens. Das gibt es bei uns auch nicht.
Und es wird genau dort angewendet, wo... Also das ist auch ein sehr fragwürdiges...
Ich finde es sehr wichtig, überhaupt mal in der Politik dieses Eingeständnis zu haben, wir sind hier umgeben von lauter Sachen, die wir nicht wirklich verstanden haben. Wir wissen nicht, ob unsere Maßnahmen wirken werden. Also machen wir sie erst mal nur temporär und gucken, ob sie funktionieren. Dieses Verständnis, so wenig das funktioniert in der Praxis in Amerika, so wenig das funktioniert, was ich überhaupt nicht bestreiten will, dass das komplette Makulatur ist und der Paint Redact wird jedes Jahr wieder verlängert.
Ich meine, das ist eine Forderung, die wir schon sehr lange haben.
Genau, es gibt sehr gute Argumente dagegen. Wenn man das nämlich als Steuerung eines Systems betrachtet, dann haben Steuerungen mit einem Herfallsdatum eher aufschiebende Effekte als tatsächlich sanktionierende oder Effekte, die zu einer Wirkung führen. Ganz klassisch ist zum Beispiel super, als das politische Modell häufig besprochen, sehr intensiv erforscht worden, was ist eigentlich mit Ankündigung von Steuererhöhungen. Dass also nicht eine Steuer erhöht, sondern es ankündigst, es zu tun. Wenn du zum Beispiel sagst, ab 1.1.2016 werden Lebensversicherungen besteuert. Geht dann irgendwie vorher so eine Spitze hoch und die Leute denken, jetzt noch mal schnell Lebensversicherungen oder hat das überhaupt keinen Einfluss oder was funktioniert, verändern sich dir die Angebote? Ich glaube, in dem Moment, wo man Sachen macht, von dem man schon vorher einplant, dass sie wieder scheitern können und von dem man schon vorher so eine gewisse Unsicherheit mitkommuniziert hat, können sie eine völlig andere Wirkung haben.
Aber es gibt da ein Gegenbeispiel, also zum Beispiel bei Überwachungs- und sonstigen Sicherheitsgesetzen, ist so eine Befristung mit einer Pflicht zur Evaluation und dem Nachweis, dass sie tatsächlich helfen, nach irgendwie vorher festgelegten objektiven Kriterien, gibt es ja in einigen Ländern auch und da ist es ja auch...
Echt, wo denn?
Wo denn?
Skandinavien.
Skandinavien, ja.
Ach, ist ja krass.
Ja, und die nehmen auch Sachen wieder zurück. In Österreich.
In Österreich ist das genauso passiert, aber das ist richtig.
Also es gibt...
Ich würde das aber noch... Das Prinzip je nach Feld, ja.
Das Prinzip funktioniert nicht für alle. Aber insbesondere halt bei Sozial-, Finanz- und ähnlichen Dingen stimm ich zu, dass wahrscheinlich die Second-Order-Effekte halt nicht vorhersagbar sind oder möglicherweise kontraproduktiv sind. Bei anderen Sachen, wie zum Beispiel halt eben bei Wachungssicherheitsgesetzen, also Befugnissen für den Staat, die sich eigentlich gegen den Bürger richten. Und man sagt, wir brauchen die jetzt aber gerade, weil wir haben eine besondere Situation oder wir haben eine Situation, die neu ist und wir müssen mal ausprobieren, was jetzt eigentlich funktioniert, finde ich tatsächlich so ein Ablaufdatum an solchen Maßnahmen mit Evaluationspflicht. Also dem Nachweis, dass es irgendwie funktioniert, den einzigen Weg tatsächlich zu einer rationalen Diskussion über solche Gesetze zu kommen. Weil wir haben ja vorher keine Datenbasis.
Aber vielleicht, das mag sein, aber vielleicht ist da auch ein Ablaufdatum eingebaut, dass gar nicht die klügste Art und Weise damit umzugehen. Vielleicht muss man das auf einer viel höheren Ebene.
Na gut, wäre, wenn die Politiker von selber auf die Idee kommen würden, aber.
Ja, oder vielleicht muss man auch mit General-Evaluationspflicht. Also, dass es nicht ein Datum gibt, bis erst im 793 ist es das Ding, sondern wenn ein Gesetz nach drei Jahren nicht nachweisen kann, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, der Nachweis ist halt immer sehr schwierig. Ich glaube, das ist.
Aber den musst du ja auch machen, wenn das Gesetz einen Ablaufdatum.
Nee, aber das ist genau das Ding wie vorhin mit dem Rückgang in Kriminalität. Da gibt es mehrere wirklich solider aussehende Theorien, warum die Kriminalität so zurückgegangen ist in den USA. Und die eine ist eben, dass es plötzlich erlaubt war, abzutreiben. Und dass einfach die ganzen unterprivilegierten Familien nicht mehr gezwungen wurden, irgendwelche Kinder aufzuziehen, die dann eben sich der Kriminalität zugewandt haben, weil sie sonst keine Perspektiven hatten. Und die andere ist, dass...
Was an Freakonomics so...
Genau, das ist eine Theorie, die finde ich sehr nachvollziehbar. Und die andere ist eben, dass der Bleigehalt im Wasser zurückging.
Also überhaupt in der gesamten Luft.
In der gesamten Luft verboten.
Und das Blei nachweisbar, dass die BTs auslösen oder...
Ja, das weiß man.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es so ist. Ich kannte diese Theorie nicht.
Also die Koalition ist der schönste Koalition.
Ich finde das alles diskutabel. Und das hat natürlich auch immer so Gegen- und Für-Argument. Ich glaube, dass allerwenigsten Dinge tatsächlich monokausal passieren überhaupt. Aber der Teil, der mich hauptsächlich interessiert, ist gar nicht so sehr, warum am Ende die Kriminalität tatsächlich runtergegangen ist. Ich rede jetzt mal nicht von den USA, sondern sagen wir mal von hier, sondern welchen Anteil man durch aktive Steuerung daran überhaupt haben kann.
Also wie groß das Steuerungspotenzial ist.
Und das ist deswegen für mich die Kernfrage übrigens an fast allen Dingen, weil das die Unterscheidung ist, ob dieser ganze politische Apparat, den wir uns aufgebaut haben und wo wir vorher schon festgestellt haben, wir stützen ja ganz ordentlich mit, dass der so funktioniert, ob der einfach ganz grundsätzlich falsch aufgebaut ist, ob das alles eine Fance ist, ob es überhaupt gar keine Fance ist. Also ich tendiere dazu, dass die Politik zwar relativ viel, aber eben nicht alles steuern kann. Und ich tendiere aber auch dazu, dass von der Bevölkerung gerade die Bereiche, wo eigentlich klar ist, die sind kaum zu steuern, trotzdem in den Verantwortungsbereich der Politik geschoben werden. Also da muss doch jemand gefälligst dafür verantwortlich sein.
Ich hab neulich ein Zitat gelesen, ich hab leider vergessen von wem, aber die Aussage war, Demokratie oder Politik ist ein Instrument, mit dem sich die Bevölkerung die Hände reinwäscht von den schlimmen Dingen, die getan werden müssen.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts.
Klingt mit Churchill.
Nee, aber ich glaube, dass das einfach wahr ist, weil im Grunde jeden Einzelnen, in dem du fragst, ob der Hartz-Viersatz ausreicht, wird dir sagen, finde ich nicht.
Da hast du noch nicht FDP-Anhänger, okay, sind auch schwer zu finden.
Die gibt es ja kaum noch. Aber wenn du dir anguckst, so wollen wir denn tatsächlich, dass hier die Tore geöffnet werden für die Migrantenfluten aus Afrika? Wir sind auf der einen Seite alle dagegen, dass die Mittelmeer absaufen, auf der anderen Seite will aber auch die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung, dass die irgendwo aufgehalten werden. Und dafür haben wir die Politik in meinen Augen.
Dass die eben ein Puffer ist zwischen uns, die den Scheiß macht.
Nein, aber so ist es doch bei fast allen Sachen im Leben. Du möchtest, dass jemand sich kümmert, aber du möchtest, dass dir dann auch schuld ist. Und du möchtest vor allem dann in allen anderen Fällen sagen, naja, dafür haben wir doch die Politik.
Das Migrantenbeispiel ist auf 19 verschiedene Arten nicht gut, um smilem vorsichtig zu sein. Was damit anfängt, dass es für mich einen Unterschied gibt zwischen mehr Ertrinken lassen und die direkte Weiterleitung in irgendwelche Staaten. Damit fängt es an, der zweite, ist, dass man das kann man nur geopolitisch betrachten. Das kann man gar nicht aus nur europäischer Perspektive betrachten.
Ich meinte das jetzt nicht inhaltlich als Beispiel, sondern als ein Punkt, wo man sagt, da möchte jeder, dass jemand was tut, aber ich möchte nicht derjenige sein, der schuld ist, wenn das Böse ist, was getan wird.
Ich möchte jetzt halt die moralisch problematische Entscheidung nicht fällen.
Aber die Bevölkerung stellt sich die Schuldfrage nicht. Ich glaube fast niemand in der Bevölkerung, inklusive uns, also das ist gar nicht so ein elitistisches Denken, sondern inklusive uns stellt sich nicht die Frage, ob meine Meinung im politischen Bereich A, B oder C irgendwelche Konsequenzen hat, an denen ich am Ende schuld bin.
Weil du nicht der Kanzler bist. Dafür haben wir den Kanzler.
Also ich sehe das tatsächlich nicht so, weil letztendlich ist es so, dass der, meine gerade wir haben in unserer doch durchaus Rolle als Multiplikatoren, hat unsere Meinung schon einen Einfluss. Und die Frage...
Hoffe ich auch immer.
Und die Frage ist letzten...
Das reden wir uns alle ein.
Nee, aber tatsächlich hat sie zumindest den Einfluss auf die Meinung anderer Menschen. So und die Frage, ob diese Delegation moralischer Verantwortung in die Politik hinein, ob die der ausschlaggebende Mechanismus ist, da habe ich gewisse Zweifel. Weil zum einen haben wir festgestellt, dass das Steuerungspotenzial der Politik relativ begrenzt in vielen Bereichen. In anderen Bereichen ist es sehr groß. Also es richtet sich halt immer nach dem, was geht so. Aber diese Delegation von, da sollen die sich mal drum kümmern, das ist ja sozusagen nicht mein Problem. Da versuchen wir halt irgendwie Wege zu finden, die möglicherweise blöde Kompromisse sind. Hauptsache, da passiert nicht so viel Veränderung, ist ja auch eine Delegation von Wünschen. Also wir wünschen uns ja, nicht wir, aber zumindest die Menschen, die Merkel wählen, wünschen sich ja, dass sich nichts verändert. Das ist keine...
Dass es nicht schlimmer wird.
Im Grunde willst du schon, dass es sich verändert, aber es soll nicht schlimmer werden.
Es glaubt halt niemand mehr daran, dass es besser wird. Also der Glaube ist eigentlich...
Oh, das glaub ich sogar noch nicht.
Also kannst du dir Umfragen angucken. Es gibt mittlerweile weltweit relativ viele Umfragen dazu. Wird es deinen Kindern besser gehen als dir?
Also auf der Ebene ja.
Und die Mehrheit der Leute sagt nein. Also mittlerweile sind wir an dem Punkt, dass die Mehrheit der Leute in den befragten Nenner, meistens der Westen, sagt, es wird meinen Kindern nicht besser gehen als mir. Wir haben den Peak erreicht. Und daraus assoziiert halt der Wunsch, dass es möglichst nicht schlechter werden soll. Sollte meinen Kindern wenigstens so gut gehen wie mir. Es hat sozusagen, das geht noch vielleicht möglicherweise so. Und das geht wahrscheinlich nur, wenn wir möglich nicht so viele Veränderungen haben. Weil Veränderung ist eigentlich erst mal schlecht. Also spätestens wenn du 55 bist, ist Veränderung schlecht.
Also für viele Leute ist Veränderung schon vorher schlecht. Und ich würde das gar nicht so als Altersphänomen betrachten.
Lass mich noch kurz noch einen Punkt zu Ende bringen. Und daraus resultiert natürlich aber auch, dass diese Verantwortungsdelegation in die Politik hinein, also dieses, was Fefe gerade sagt, irgendwie moralisch schwierige Entscheidungen treffen, die halt irgendwie nicht, also wo deine Überzeugung für grundlegende Menschenrechte gegen deine eigenen ökonomischen Interessen stehen und so weiter. Also das sind ja so die Klassiker, jetzt ohne konkrete Benennung von Problemverhältnissen, wo wir jetzt jetzt wieder hineinbegeben, dass diese Art von Delegationen hat natürlich auch schon was von so einem Ablasshandel.
Auf jeden Fall gewissensbasierter.
So alle vier Jahre, wir geben es mal denen, von denen wir glauben, dass wir uns hinterher am wenigsten ärgern.
Und wenn es scheiße läuft, kann ich immer noch sagen, ich habe die nicht gewählt.
Oder ich habe sie gewählt, aber die scheiß Politiker haben sie.
Das ist doch die perfekte Delegation von moralischer Verantwortung von mir weg zu anderen.
Ich habe mich mit dieser These noch nicht auseinandergesetzt. Ich finde sie sehr interessant. Ich überlege, ob sie nicht ein stark antidemokratisches Potenzial hat.
Hat sie.
Aber was leider...
Fühlst du dich denn verantwortlich, wenn ich das mal sagen darf?
Ja, aber auf andere Art. Für Sachen, die zum Beispiel die SPD tut? Ich versuche gleich mal meine Position zu der Verantwortung noch zu skizzieren. Aber es gibt einen Punkt, der leider in diesem Kontext, muss man ja sagen, dir recht gibt, Frank. Es gibt einen vergleichsweise bekannt gewordenen Leserbrief. Ich glaube, der ging an mehrere Zeitungen. Der Spiegel hat es aber auf jeden Fall auch abgedruckt von jemandem, der sich so nach zwei Jahren FDP, schwarz-gelber Regierung entschuldigt hat dafür, dass er Guido Westerwelle gewählt hat. Er sei einer von denen, die 14 Prozent waren, die die Guido Westerwelle an die Macht als Vizekanzler an Außenminister gemacht haben. Er müsse sich jetzt ganz fürchterlich dafür entschuldigen. Das hat er so nicht gewollt. Das hat er nicht gesehen. Und aus diesem Leserbrief spricht eine ganze Menge von dem, was du gerade so adressiert hast. Unter anderem nämlich, ich habe einfach alles, was ich da wollte, habe ich in der FDP. Und jetzt, wo es nicht so gut läuft, wo sie aber exakt das tut, was sie vorher versprochen hat, das war ja der Witz, genau das Gleiche, genau gemacht, was sie gesagt hat. Also die FDP hat praktisch gar keinen Bruch ihrer Versprechungslogik begangen.
Musste sie nicht.
Ja, aber genau sie tut das, was sie versprochen hat, vorher gesagt hat, ganz konsequent. Und dann tun Leute hinterher so, als können sie sich rückwirkend dafür schämen und distanzieren. Und das finde ich erstaunlich bis krass, weil das für mich bedeutet, die haben zum einen nur ein Image gewählt, was halt so medial hin und her weht. Das waren 14 Prozent, die konnten ins Wahlprogramm gucken, hat keiner gemacht. Die haben Guido Westerwelle gehört, der war vorher gegen Hartz IV, er war danach gegen Hartz IV Empfänger. Der hat vorher fiese Sachen gesagt, der hat danach fiese Sachen gesagt. Es war einfach völlig so konstant, was da passiert ist. Und auf einmal tun die Leute so, als hätten sie das totale Überraschungspaket bekommen. Da haben die doch tatsächlich den Hoteliers steuern lassen. Ja, fuck. Das haben sie vorher gesagt. Die CSU hat es übrigens auch gesagt. Eigentlich kommt das von der CSU. Es ist total bekannt, dass die FDP immer Klientelpolitik macht. Wer davon überrascht ist und dann so tut, als müsste sie sich schämen. Das ist echt eine Unverschämtheit. Und das spricht so ein bisschen für deine These, dass man halt einfach jemanden sucht, von dem man hofft, dass er irgendwie gut aussieht mit der eigenen politischen Meinung. Und wenn es halt nicht mehr so gut läuft, dann geht man so schnell weg. Und das Traurige daran ist, das macht Merkels vorgehen so verständlich. Das ist halt so, wenn du so näher rangehst und man hat vielleicht an meinem publizistischen Irrwürde den Eindruck gewidmet, dass ich jetzt nicht der allerbeste Freund von Angela Merkel bin in den letzten Jahren. Was auch stimmt, das ist nicht nur ein oberflächlicher Eindruck, das stimmt auch tatsächlich. Aber je näher man rangeht, desto mehr muss man zugeben, dass das, was sie tut, ganz handfeste Gründe hat, die man auch nicht wegdiskutieren kann. Sondern es wird fast offensichtlich und fast klar, warum sie so ist, wie sie ist. Man kann dann noch beklagen, dass sie es trotzdem tut, aber man sieht wenigstens warum.
Also die inhärente Logik ihres Handelns ist eigentlich relativ bestechend, muss man schon so sagen.
Ja, und das ist halt total traurig, weil man halt davor steht und eine völlig andere Überzeugung hat. Ja, und es ist bei mir in einem bestimmten Moment explodiert auch im Jahr 2013 vor den Wahlen, als sie nämlich in einem Fernsehduell mit Steinendrück gefragt wurde, warum sie jetzt denn die Homo-Ehe nicht will. Und letztlich war da so ein bisschen Rumlavieren und dann kam als Urgrund, ich fühle mich damit nicht so wohl, ich habe da nicht so ein gutes Gefühl bei. Dieser Moment hat mich so aggressiv gemacht. Der hat mich so traurig und aggressiv gleichzeitig gemacht. Zum einen glaube ich, es war tatsächlich wahr, und zwar gar nicht für sie, sondern für die Bevölkerung. Sie hat einen Grund genannt, wo sie mit Sicherheit vorher von anderen gehört hat, dass das der Grund sei, warum die Mehrheit eher so ein bisschen skeptisch ist. Jedenfalls die CDU-Wählermehrheit, die fühlen sich halt nicht so wohl, wenn da so zwei Männer herkommen.
Ich glaube, das war die Antwort bei der Umfrage, die die Leute geklickt haben.
Genau. Das sind so Momente, wo du merkst, es ist eine bestechende Logik, aber die ist eklig. Es funktioniert und es ist richtig, das so zu tun von der Machtperspektive aus, aber es ist eklig. Es soll nicht so sein.
Der Punkt dabei ist ja, dass so ein System funktioniert ja genau so lange, wie es sich nicht verwundbar macht, für prinzipienideologische Angreifer. Dieses System Merkel funktioniert genau so lange, wie die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung der Meinung ist, dass das Veränderung schlecht ist.
Wechselstimmung nennt man das ja in der Wahlartnötig.
Wechselstimmung hat häufig mit Personen zu tun. Das würde ich jetzt nicht so... Es geht mir um den prinzipiellen Politikstil. Wenn wir uns mal angucken, Ungarn als krasses Gegenbeispiel, wo es ja so war, dass die Leute, die da voran waren, waren so ein bisschen Merkel-Style. Die haben halt so eine Realpolitik gemacht, die halt irgendwie relativ flexibel war. Die haben halt irgendwie Liberalisierung betrieben, also Wirtschaftsliberalisierung und politische Liberalisierung zusammen, also kombiniert. Und die wirtschaftliche Liberalisierung hat dazu geführt, dass sie sich halt alle Häuser gekauft haben für Kredite, die auf Schweizer Franken und österreichische Euro ausgestellt waren. Und als dann die Karre gegen die Wand fuhr, war halt dieses System des flexiblen, politischen, liberalen, ist nach unten ausgeschlagen, vor sich hin verwaltend und halt irgendwie quasi so rationale Politikstil ist mit einem Mal komplett gekippt und rangekommen sind Leute, die sagen, nee, wir wollen keine Beliebigkeit mehr, wir wollen halt Prinzipien, wir haben halt irgendwie diese Prinzipien irgendwie.
Hab das eigentlich, ich weiß nicht, ich bin da leider politikhistorisch nicht so firm, aber hat das mal jemand in einer anderen Weise funktioniert, weil Ungarn sind ja einfach Nazis und Rechtsradikale.
Das ist immer schleichend.
Andersrum, dass man einfach gesagt hat, wir brauchen jetzt wieder Prinzipien und dann aber so liberale linke Thesen vorgetragen hat. Geht es überhaupt, wäre noch meine Frage.
Na jetzt wird es langsam wieder Zeit, glaube ich.
Also es gibt immer wieder Gelegenheiten, wo es geht. Und ich denke mal, dass halt das Ende der Wachstumsideologie, die absehbar ist, dass die wieder so eine Chance ist. Ob die Linke diese Möglichkeit nutzt, habe ich große Zweifel. Also ich habe eher so das Bauchgefühl, dass halt zusammen mit den sonstigen Krisen, die wir sonst noch so haben, ist dann halt eher wieder zu einer Polarisierung kommen wird. Also dass halt der liberale linkere Flügel sich auch wieder mal ein bisschen ideologisiert wird, weil er halt in der Abtrennung gegen ein rechtes ideologisches System sich mal wieder so ein bisschen zusammenraufen muss. Aber tatsächlich ist der typische Ablauf halt eher so eine Abgrenzung fremdenfeindlich zu machen. Das ist ein nationaler Tendenz weg von so einer Beliebigkeit.
Ich muss ja sagen, eine Beobachtung kurz mit euch teilen, nämlich dass sowohl das System Merkel als auch ein sehr ideologisches System beide im Grunde darauf ausgelegt sind, dem Wähler gegenüber Sicherheit auszustrahlen. Ich weiß vorher, was kommen wird. Warum ist es eigentlich so, dass es so auf Sicherheit geht? Und warum versucht keiner zu sagen, Leute, ich sage euch vorher nicht, was passiert. Wir werden das Richtige tun. Wir werden jetzt hier mal die Probleme lösen. Warum macht das eigentlich keiner?
Es gibt einen sehr interessanten Artikel von Dietmar Daert, einer FAZ, der heißt Westblog, Ostblog, Webblog, glaube ich. Also diese drei Begriffe zusammen. Ein bisschen bemüht, aber da drin skizzierte unter anderem eine Ideologie der Ideologielosigkeit. Er hat das damals ein bisschen in Richtung der Piraten geschossen, die dann halt behauptet haben, sie hätten kein Links und kein Rechts. Und dass das eigentlich auch eine Form von Ideologie ist, nämlich die Abwesenheit von Ideologie. Und zwar genau in dem Moment, wo man so tut, als hätte man keine Ideologie, ist das halt ein hochideologischer Move. Also ich verallgemeinere und vereinfache ein bisschen da seine Artikelauslage. Und das könnte man eben versuchen, mal auf Merkel anzuwenden. Da könnte man sich dann mal fragen, ob dieses Vortäuschen davon, man habe keine Ideologie, nicht auch eine eisenharte Ideologie ist, die Merkel da vorträgt. Das ist jetzt erst mal nur eine Frage. Es ist noch keine These. Also es ist jetzt auch nichts, was ich behaupten würde. Aber es wäre eine spannende Fragestellung.
Also ich denke, da könnte was dran sein, weil das generell vermeiden von echten Wertedebatten. Gibt es ja nur Fake-Werte-Debatten. Und das generell nicht festlegen auf, also auch auf soziale Werte.
Merkel ist werte-averse, ganz klar.
Das hat schon den Rang eines ideologischen des Themes eingenommen, denke ich mal. Also ich meine, es gibt halt Dinge, wo es nicht so ist. Also zum Beispiel halt irgendwie Garniens Politik, wo halt schon man klar sieht, dass also der...
Da gibt es so ein Fundament, was keiner anfasst.
Genau, also halt so das atlantische Fundament anzufassen geht nicht, wie wir jetzt gelernt haben.
Das ist richtig. Und auch dahinter gibt es ja sehr vernünftige Argumente, warum das nicht gehen soll. Also nicht, dass ich die jetzt alle teile, aber diese Anknüpfungspunkte, das ist ja das Spannende. Da kann man gegen oder für ganz viele sein, aber dass sie erstmal faktisch da sind, Wir sind jetzt weder in der Westzone noch in der Ostzone, weil dann ganz komische Machtprozesse einsetzen würden. Das finde ich erstmal als Argument legitim. Die Problematik. Ja, aber da ist ja auch wahrscheinlich unsere unterschiedlichen Biografien dann ein bisschen im Hintergrund. Aber die Problematik, die sich daraus für mich ergibt, die findet sich in einem schönen Zitat wieder von einem amerikanischen Schriftsteller, dessen Name mir gerade entfallen ist. Das heißt, there is a certain shit I won't eat. Also eine bestimmte Scheiße werde ich nicht fressen, quasi eine rote Linie zu ziehen.
Es gibt ein Hardlimit.
Und ich bin eigentlich immer ganz froh über Leute, die zumindest aufblitzen lassen, dass das so ist. Und ich weiß jetzt zum Beispiel in dem Kontext auch gar nicht, und da ist denn Merkels Politik total schädlich, auch die Informationspolitik, die nicht vorhanden ist, faktisch. Wie sind diese Verhandlungen? Gab es Verhandlungen? Sind die mit den Amerikanern, wie sind die abgelaufen? Was ist der Gegenwert, den Merkel dafür bekommen hat, dass sie jetzt schon wieder vergessen hat, dass ihr Handy abgehört wurde? Was laufen da für Prozesse im Hintergrund ab? Ist es tatsächlich so, dass diese totale Überwachung, von der ich überzeugt bin, weil da Papiere sind, die nicht widersprochen würden, die das beweisen, es ist tatsächlich so, dass, wie vermutet wurde, sich auf der höchsten politischen Ebene Leute getroffen haben und gesagt haben, wir müssen immer zu, selbst wenn wir jetzt hier einen Knopf drücken würden und sagen würden, das darf nicht mehr passieren, passiert es trotzdem. Wenn wir da zu tief reingehen, dann, also es gibt dieses Gerücht, also da wären wir wieder bei dem Obama, kann er überhaupt den Geheimdienstapparat abschalten? Ja oder nein, wenn er es wollte. Das ist eine Frage, die man stellen muss. Und die ist mir deswegen unangenehm, weil sie halt eines Verschwörungstheoretischen dran grenzt und die haben nicht wirklich die Macht. Aber ich würde das halt nicht verschwörungstheoretisch nennen, sondern eben eher das Beherrungsvermögen eines nachweislich milliardenschweren Apparates, wo vielleicht gar nicht mehr...
Ich glaube, es gibt auch tatsächlich handfeste Vorteile, die Merkel aus dem Abhören hat. Das ist einfach so ein Geben und Nehmen aus der Intel, die du abhörst.
Da würde mich interessieren, was...
Ich glaube, das ist einfach ausreichend als Argument, unabhängig von irgendwelchen Kompromatkoffern, die es mit Sicherheit gibt, ist das als Argument völlig ausreichend zu sagen, hey, wenn wir bei euch nicht mehr abhören, dann kriegt ihr aber auch unsere Erkenntnisse nicht mehr. Und dann geht morgen bei euch ein Terrorist irgendwie in den Bahnhof und dann kannst du ja mal überlegen, wie deine Umfragewerte aussehen. Ja, so, also diese Art von Argument ist einfach greifend genug, dass ich mir denke, über den Rest müssen wir auch gar nicht mehr reden. Weil es gibt einfach handfeste Argumente, mit denen du jeden Politiker kriegst, wie eben genau diese Security-Schiene.
Da sind wir dann übrigens sofort wieder in einem schönen Bogen bei Überwachung als Ideologie. Also das ist ja so eine urkonservative Haltung eigentlich, dass mehr Überwachung besser ist und zwar in ungefähr allen Kontexten.
Ich mein, es ist halt diese Geschichte mit dem Kindergartengott.
Ja, Moment.
Also wenn du diese Leute anguckst, wie die groß geworden sind und was die für eine Sozialisierung haben, denen wurde halt im Kindergarten schon erzählt, es gibt da halt irgendwie diesen Kindergartengott, der sieht alles, der weiß alles und der passt auf dich auf. So und der ist halt irgendwann verloren gegangen.
Den möchte man jetzt nachspielen.
Den jetzt wieder zu bauen, ist irgendwie nur eine, also psychologisch als nicht unregend.
Ich glaube auch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das eine konservative Sache ist. Im Gegenteil, es gibt viele Konservative, die eher für die Verkleinerung des Staates sind, was eigentlich heißt, weniger Sicherheitsapparat.
Doch, natürlich. Aber nicht in dem Bereich.
Ideologisch sind sie so, aber sie können es nicht machen, weil es eben Argumente gibt, die sie daran hindern. Aber es ist nicht Teil ihrer Ideologie. Ich widerspreche jetzt nicht inhaltlich, sondern ich sage, wenn du sagst die Konservativen.
Also ich glaube, die konservative Ideologie ist eigentlich eine andere. Das ist jetzt wieder so eine Begrifflichkeitssache. Ich habe gesagt, es ist ein konservativer Ansatz. Ich sehe zum Beispiel bei der SPD ein paar Innenminister, die einfach, die würden in der CDU wegen Extremismus rausgeworfen quasi. Es ist so, wenn man sich Ralf Jäger anguckt, was er in NRW so vorträgt, da denkst du, das hätte sich Schill kaum getraut. Also so richtig der krasse, ist sehr hardcore. Aber da sehe ich, da ist vielleicht konservativ tatsächlich das falsche Begriffsmuster. Es gibt halt irgendwo eine Überzeugung, dass Überwachung eine Lösung von irgendwas ist. Und das Spannende ist, dass das zusammenhängt, wenn man das auf einer philosophischen Ebene betrachtet, mit einer Sache, die ich mit Gerd Gigerenzer neulich durch Zufall besprochen habe. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Gerd Gigerenzer kennt.
Er ist Psychologe.
Übrigens war er auch ein Freund oder ein guter Bekannter von Schirmmacher, der sich wendet gegen den Glaube, man könnte alles vorhersagen. Er hat ein paar Bücher darüber geschrieben. Der ist der natürliche Gegenspieler von Kahnemann. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Kahnemann kennt, der Nobelpreisträger. Schnelles Denken, langsames Denken. Und aus der Kahnemann-Ecke kommt mit den Verfassern des Buches Nudge die Gedankenwelt von David Cameron. Nudge ist auch ein Bestseller gewesen von zwei Briten.
So die Self-Help-Version von Kahnemann.
Man muss nur so und so machen, wir helfen dir jetzt mal. Nudge ist halt ein Buch und ich glaube eine Ideologie und ich glaube eine gefährliche Ideologie. Man könne Leute mit einem bestimmten Anreizsystem dazu bringen, klüger zu werden. Das ist halt eine Kontrollideologie. Du musst nur ein paar Fäden ziehen und dann kommen die Leute von alleine drauf, dass es viel besser ist, langsam mit dem Auto zu fahren.
Ich glaube übrigens, dass es unsere Schuld ist, dass die Leute für Überwachung sind.
Meine Schuld ist, bin ich total wütend.
Unsere Schuld ist mit der Überwachung. Das passt gerade perfekt deswegen bei diesem Anruf. Denn wir erzählen den Politikern seit vielen Jahren, wenn ihr mehr Überwachung macht, dann sorgt das dafür, dass die Leute im Kopf wissen, sie werden überwacht und ihr Verhalten ändert. Und das ist genau, was die hoffen. Deswegen machen die Überwachung.
Und das ist genau, das passt tatsächlich perfekt, weil dieses Nudge, und wie gesagt, ein sehr spannendes Gespräch mit Giga Renzler gewesen. Dieses Nudge geht davon aus, dass du Menschen als System, als Gesellschaft, als System steuern kannst, wenn du genügend Parameter kennst. Du kannst sie zu richtigen und besseren Entscheidungen, die sie glauben, selbst zu treffen, bringen.
Und weißt du, wie das früher hieß? Entwickelte sozialistische Persönlichkeit.
Das ist exakt genau die selbe Idee. Das ist deswegen spannend, weil es tatsächlich Ansätze bei Cameron gibt, das genauso durchzuziehen.
Nein, nicht nur Ansätze. Der hat sich zwei High-Profile-Berater aus genau diesem Umfeld genommen.
Das ist eigentlich aktenkundig.
Und in Deutschland ist der Vertreter übrigens da von der Bertelsmann Stiftung. Also die hört immer in diese Richtung gehen. Also die sagen, okay, wir...
Da hab ich nicht genug Verschwörungstheorien zu gelesen.
Also wir brauchen nicht noch mehr Regeln.
Ich muss an dieser Stelle übrigens, damit das nicht irgendjemand in die Kommentare... Habt ihr da Kommentare geschrieben?
Linus hat Kommentare.
Ich bin auf mehreren Ebenen geschäftlich mit dem Bertelsmann Konzern verwunden. Nicht direkt, aber ich hab mal da ein Buch geschrieben und ich habe von denen schon mal Aufträge bekommen. Das ist nur nebenbei. Und Sobooks verkauft Bertelsmann Bücher. Dann haben wir jetzt also meine...
Das wird jetzt gerade rausgeschnitten.
Bertelsmann ist der größte Buchverlag der Welt.
Also einer meiner Verleger ist auch random houses, auch Bertelsmann. Habt ihr da kein Problem?
Ich wollte es nur sagen, damit da nicht Verschwörungstheorien herausfinden, dass alles ganz schlimm ist und nicht bezahlt wird.
Nee, also die Bertelsmann Stiftung ist tatsächlich in Deutschland einer der großen Proponenten von dieser Ideologie, die im sozialen Bereich ist. Es gibt total Bertelsmann Stiftungen, die irgendwie durch das gute Dinge tun, aber was halt irgendwie diesen Sozial-Arbeits- und sonstigen Bereich angeht, gehen die genau in diese Richtung. Also zu sagen, wir müssen halt nicht Leute explizit kontrollieren, wir müssen nicht so viele Vorschriften machen, sondern wir wollen eigentlich mit Anreizen dafür sorgen, dass sie das Richtige tun und wir definieren aber, was das Richtige ist. Und das ist halt exakt genau. Präzise, lindinistische Ideologie.
Aber der spannende Punkt bei Cameron, das Bertelsmann Stiftung kenne ich nicht so wenig.
Aber an sich ist es ja was Gutes. Also wenn du den letzten Teil weglässt, ist es ja eigentlich was Gutes, wenn du sagst, wir wollen ihn, wir wollen ihn.
Nein, nein, genau.
Es ist mir viel lieber, wenn sie das irgendwie per Anreiz machen, den ich ignorieren kann, als wenn sie einen Holzhammer haben und ich einen Knast traue.
Nein, nein, nein, Moment. Und jetzt kommt Komponente dazu, wo wir interessanterweise noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen haben. Das beste Instrument für diese Überwachungs- und Anreizstrukturierung der Gesellschaft ist die digitale Vernetzung mit weitem Abstand. Ich habe ja relativ viele Vorträge, die ich halte. Das ist mein Hauptjob, ist tatsächlich Vorträge zu halten.
Kannst du das irgendwie begründen? Oder ist das so ein Talking-Point, der gut klingt?
Wie?
Ich meine, ich finde das spontan irgendwie die These. Ob die Vernetzung hilft, erzähl mal zusammen.
Das ist der Bogen. In dem Vortrag habe ich ein Beispiel, was ich glaube ich sehr gut illustriert. Wenn du dir nämlich Car2go anguckst. Car2go, dieses System, wo du spontan Mietwagen mieten kannst. Das funktioniert eigentlich nur durch eine extrem flexible, hochmobile Technologie mit Smartphone. Du kannst halt immer sehen, wo ist das nächste freie Auto. Du kannst es buchen, du kannst dahin, schließt es mit dem Smartphone auf. Es basiert eigentlich in seiner ganzen Struktur als Geschäftsmodell auf der digitalen Vernetzung. Was erstmal super ist. Und dann guckst du dir in die Mittelkonsole von diesem Car2go-Dingsbums und da sind so drei Bäumchen, die deinen Eco-Score ergeben. Das ist Bremsverhalten, Konstanz im Fahren und ich glaube Anfahren. Das sind so drei Werte zwischen 0 und 100. Und das sind so drei Bäumchen und je größer der Wert ist, desto besser du bist, das ist ein Anreizsystem, desto mehr Laub hattest, mehr ganz grün.
Aber das hat keine finanziellen Auswirkungen, das ist nur rein? Ach so.
In dem Moment, also indirekt, in dem Moment, wo du anfängst, schlecht zu fahren, wie ein Henker, Vollbremsung zu machen, anzufahren an der Ampel, da verlieren diese Bäumchen Laub. Und sie verlieren immer mehr Laub und da ist ein Eichhörnchen drin und ein paar Vögel und irgendwann fällt das Eichhörnchen runter und die Vögel fliegen weg und dann verliert der Baum das Laub. Und dann kommt irgendwann so ein Pop-Up, das sagt, wenn du weiter so scheiße fährst, dann wirst du für immer ausgeschlossen. Das bedeutet, irgendwann hast du eine massive Sanktion, dass du dich gefälligst richtig verhältst. Und die Leute machen da, das ist sowieso Gemmification-Element, würde man in der Bullshit-Branche sagen, die Leute machen da so, ich habe 100 Punkte und so und das ist total geil. Und tatsächlich ist es ein Anreizsystem, wie du möglichst unauffällig fährst, mit ganz vielen schlimmen Nebenwirkungen. Man kann zum Beispiel relativ gut nachweisen, dass wenn du den Leuten sagst, stark bremsen ist schlecht, dass sie dann eher Unfälle machen, wo sie eigentlich stark bremsen müssen, weil sie eigentlich davor zurückzucken, mein Score mit dem Bremsen. Dieses Modell Car2Go, was so eine Verflüssigung der Produktlandschaft ist, Service statt Produkt, was halt über das Internet, quasi dieses Sharing-Modell, Mobilitätsservice und so. Mobilitätsservice, was überhaupt durch das Internet dramatisch ermöglicht worden ist, das ist gleichzeitig ganz fantastisch dazu geeignet, weil du einen Service halt sperren kannst, zu sanktionieren, Fehlverhalten. In dem Moment, wo du nicht mehr ein Produkt hast, sondern Service. Und in diese Richtung geht es. Musik zum Beispiel ist ja jetzt mit Spotify nicht mehr ein Produkt, was du runterlädst und dann hast du das und dann fuck off. Sondern das ist jetzt ein Service. Und in dem Moment, wo du ein Service hast und nicht mehr ein Produkt, hast du 117 Vorteile. Und du hast den einen zentralen Nachteil, dass du die radikale Sanktion jemanden auszuschließen, immer im Hintergrund hast. Und zwar automatisch. Und das ist ein Mechanismus, wo man sagen muss, ja, die digitale Vernetzung ist großartig, ich bin jeden Tag dabei. Aber das ist gleichzeitig ziemlich gut geeignet. Wenn ich nicht dagegen arbeite, ich kann dagegen arbeiten, aber ich muss eben auch dagegen arbeiten, ist das ziemlich gut geeignet als ständiges Kontrollinstrument.
Und wo wir wieder genau zu dem Punkt kommen, wer macht die Regeln? Also die Frage ist ja letztendlich, weil so eine Dinge finden wir an vielen anderen Stellen. Also finden sie in der Arbeitswelt, wo Digitalisierung und digitale Erfassbarkeit von Arbeitsprozessen dazu führt, dass Arbeit quantifizierbar wird und dabei zumindest Lohnarbeit wird. Und wir haben solche Dinge, zum Beispiel Versicherungswesen, Pay as you drive, Krankenversicherungen, also immer mehr der Druck, Sport zu machen, wird halt irgendwie mittlerweile echt obszön.
Ich war vor ein paar Wochen am Flughafen Tegel und habe da das erste Mal eine Zahnbürste von Braun, glaube ich, gesehen, die halt mit deinem Smartphone redet. Im Anfang des Jahres wurde auch vorgestellt, auf der Messe in Las Vegas, die CES, wo immer Technologie vorgestellt wird, eine Zahnbürste namens Colibri. Und diese Zahnbürste ist halt auch so eine elektrische Zahnbürste, die mit deinem Smartphone redet. Die wird da auch noch unser Kindererziehungsgesichtspunkten vermarktet. Du hast ein richtig kleines Game auf dem Handy und die Kinder benutzen diese Zahnbürste als eine Art Bedienung dafür, so eine Art Joystick und die müssen sich halt richtig die Zahne pürsten, damit da so ein kleines Bärchen nach vorne läuft. Und du kriegst eine bestimmte Punktzahl, wenn du drei Minuten richtig pürstest, das richtige Putzmuster entwickelst. Die zeigen da, welche Zähne du geputzt hast und welche noch nicht auf deinem Smartphone. Das ist total krass. Und du musst natürlich auch dafür sorgen, sonst piept das Gerät nämlich, dass du dir morgens drei Minuten, mittags drei Minuten und abends drei Minuten die Zähne putzt. Und das ist halt so lange ein echt spannendes, tolles Stückchen Fortschritt, wie du genau weißt und jetzt schon sagen kannst, dass die nächste Zahnzusatzversicherung, die um die Ecke kommt und sagt, hey, mach doch mal hier diese Zahnbürste, kriegst du kostenlos. Und dann mit dem Smartphone und dann weise doch mal nach, dass du jeden Tag neun Uhr, um zwölf Uhr und um 18 Uhr deine Zähne putzt, weil dann wird deine Zahnzusatzversicherung einfach 40 Prozent billiger. Die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, ob wir wirklich in einer Gesellschaft leben wollen, wo mir meine Zahnbürste sagt, wenn du jetzt nicht die Zähne putzt, dann musst du 2000 Euro bezahlen.
Hier eine kleine Geschichte aus Amerika erzählen, die ich an dir stellen, so tief finde. Erst mal den Latein heraushängen lassen. Es gibt einen Begriff namens Dezimieren, den kennt man so. Der geht eigentlich zurück auf die Armee in Rom. Da haben sie nämlich Dezimieren, da ist das Kopf von Dezimus, der Zehnte. Da wird der Zehnte Teil, die schlechten Szenen werden ausgespürt, damals halt umgebracht, heute würde man halt sagen. Das Prinzip gibt es immer noch. Ja, das Prinzip gibt es immer noch. Es ist inzwischen üblich in amerikanischen Großkonzernen, dass sie bei den quartalsmäßigen Bewertungen ihrer Mitarbeiter explizit fragen, wer ist in den unteren zehn Prozent und der muss dann gehen.
Bei Microsoft hat Walmart das durchgesetzt.
Das gibt es auch bei, ich hörte glaube ich, Prompto und Gamble, also nicht nur IT-Firmen.
Diverse andere Konzerne auch.
Ja, diese Quantifizierung von Menschen, nicht nur ihre Leistung, die Quantifizierung allgemein von Sachen hat eigentlich immer so negative Auswirkungen wie das. Ich finde diese Vorstellung furchtbar, denn ich habe mich mit einem Projektmanager unterhalten, der meinte, er hat sich viel Mühe gegeben, sein Team zusammenzustellen, da gibt es keine schlechten Leute. Und er muss jetzt aber trotzdem einen benennen. Und das führt dann dazu, dass er jetzt kurzfristig irgendeinen armen Schwein einstellt, damit er jemand zum Feuern hat. Also diese ganze Quantifizierungsgeschichte, das klingt immer auf dem Papier super und was wir hier tolles erreichen. Aber am Ende wird das dazu führen, dass irgendjemand eine Zahnputzmaschine für Koli-Bri baut, die dann eben Perfect Score absahnt.
Jein, mag sein, aber bei dem Kato Go führt es halt wirklich dazu, dass die Leute weniger Benzin verbrauchen. Und zwar in so einer Größenordnung, dass man das messen kann. Der Hauptgrund ist ja, dass die Leute nicht fahren wie die Henker. Es ist ja nicht nur, dass sie das Auto dann nicht kaputt machen, sondern dass die richtig viel Benzin darüber sparen können.
Die Frage ist letztendlich, was sind die Optimierungsziele? Wie verhandeln wir diese Optimierungsziele gesellschaftlich, wo wir über der Politik wären? Und wollen wir uns darüber überhaupt unterhalten oder nehmen wir an, wenn die Forschung sagt, dass und das ist gut oder dieses und jenes Verhalten ist gut, dann ist es ein automatischer Freibrief mit Nudging oder was auch immer, dieses Ziel zu erreichen. Also nehmen wir mal Medizin, das ist ein großes Ding. Verhalten, was halt irgendwie dazu führen soll, dass du länger lebst, dass du weniger Kosten für die Allgemeinheit verursachst. Also quasi dieses inhärente Aushöhlen des Solidarprinzips, in dem wir sagen, ja, also Solidarität von der Krankenversicherung wollen wir eigentlich nur noch üben, wenn du dich vernünftig verhältst.
Ich würde es sogar konform nennen, weil vernünftig ist nur der Tantrum.
Also vernünftig war jetzt ein Anführungszeichen im Sinne von, was der momentane Stand der Wissenschaft, der beliebig falsch sein kann, also beliebig falsch sein kann, ausgibt. Wir haben eine große Abfolge von, gerade in der Medizin, von Überzeugungen, die über Jahrzehnte hinweg quasi Dogma in der Medizin waren.
Das ist recht in der Ernährungswissenschaft.
Die sich hinterher als volliger Bullshit herausgestellt hat.
Oder zumindest als nicht so Erfolg versprengt, wie man es dachte.
Spinat.
Das ist immer so das klassische Beispiel, aber ich glaube, es gibt viel wichtigere Beispiele, die auch die zu sehen nicht angehen.
Also zum Beispiel die Zusammenhang von Salz und Blutdruck ist mittlerweile hochgradig angezweifelt.
Vor 30 Jahren hat man gesagt, Cholesterin ist das Schlimmste auf der Welt. Inzwischen weiß man, es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Arten von Cholesterin. Es ist immer nicht so schlimm und es ist auch die Kausalität lässt sich so nicht herstellen. Dann gibt es diese ganz lange Diskussion, was genau macht eigentlich dick und was nicht. Ist es jetzt eher Fett, eher Kohlenhydrate, ist es Zucker, ist es eher die falsche Kombination, ist es ganz unterschiedliche Sachen. Also da gibt es sehr viele unterschiedliche Ansätze. Insofern finde ich das aus einer besonderen Sicht spannend, weil die Kritik, die können wir uns da auch als Technologie-Leute eher, also obwohl wir uns jetzt noch stark unterscheiden, ist das glaube ich aus einer Draufsicht bloß graduell die Art und Weise, wie ihr mit Technologie umgeht und wie ich mit Technologie umgehe. Aber da muss man sich fragen, ob an der Stelle nicht tatsächlich Technologie eine Konkurrenz zur Politik ist. Dass du also über solche Technologien wie Car2Go versuchst, Dinge zu lösen, die eigentlich eine klassische Aufgabe der Politik ist, wo man so denkt, die Politik muss jetzt dafür sorgen, dass wir Energie sparen. Das ist so ein klassischer Auftrag, dass weniger verbraucht wird. Das tun sie ja auch. Erlassen Gesetze, die versuchen es, sagen wir so.
Letztens ist es halt der kalifornische Ansatz, dass man sagt, dass also cleverere Menschen an der richtigen Stelle, die irgendwie in der Lage sind, das Leben durch Geschäftsmodelle zu beeinflussen, einen größeren Einfluss auf das reale Leben haben können als Politiker, die nur irgendwelche Gesetze beschließen, die sowieso niemand hält. Und das ist ja...
Antidemokratisch eigentlich.
Ja, aber das interessante Problem ist ja, also ich finde ja... Na ja, Moment, Moment.
Einmal kurz die Brücke schlagen. Vorhin meintest du, ja, aber das größere Gut ist ja das Argument, mit dem man dann seine eigenen Kompromissscheiße wegdiskutiert. Das kannst du hier genauso bringen, kannst sagen. Das ist nicht antidemokratisch, das ist genau, was wir jetzt machen. Nur wir machen halt keinen Politkompromiss, sondern wir machen einen Technikkompromiss.
Ja, und da würde ich dann aber schon auch noch sagen, für mich gibt es eine Art Primat der Politik in dem Moment, wo die Politik zumindest die Absicht hat, demokratisch legitimiert zu sein. Ja, also das unterstelle ich mal.
Aber die Frage mit diesem Nudging ist ja eigentlich immer, was ist eigentlich das Ziel und was sind die Nebenwirkungen? Das sind ja die beiden Kernparameter. Ich habe mich mit Kahnemann eine Weile beschäftigt, der einer der wissenschaftlichen Fundamente dafür ist. Und Kahnemann hat ja eine Menge sehr interessante, fundamentale Sachen rausgefunden. Also der hat halt zum Beispiel...
Der postuliert im Prinzip, dass man sowas wie einen freien Willen sich gar nicht erst mal einbilden soll.
Also das Buch haben wir schon mal in der Liste gehabt. Das werden wir jetzt wieder in die Liste tun. Kahnemann, ein sehr interessantes Buch kann ich nur empfehlen. Das ist tatsächlich bewusstseinserweitern, das auch mal zu lesen.
Also zwar das ältere Buch, nicht sein neues. Nicht dieses Thinking Fast Thinking Slow, wo einfach die Luft drinnen.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich gelesen habe.
Es gibt nämlich ein älteres, nämlich die Psychologie des Glücklichseins. Und das ist tatsächlich ein sehr, sehr interessantes Buch, weil er sich damit auseinandersetzt, wie funktioniert eigentlich Glück, wie funktioniert unser Empfinden von Glück und wie funktioniert auch der Mechanismus, dass wir uns positiv oder negativ an Dinge erinnern. So hat er viele handfeste Hinweise, wie zum Beispiel, dass wir in medizinischen Prozeduren, es eigentlich egal ist, wie doll es wehtut, solange du am Ende sozusagen es nicht so doll wehtut. Also durch sozusagen eine Degression von Schmerzempfinden hast, sozusagen nicht. Linderungsempfindungen. Und so Sachen. Und dass wir uns zum Beispiel nicht an Strecken erinnern, sondern nur quasi wie eine Perlenkette. Also das wir sozusagen immer nur im Moment erinnern. Da hat er alles gut ausbelegt. Und dann ist er irgendwann abgebogen. Und dann ist er tatsächlich irgendwann in diesem...
Ideologisch geworden.
Na ja, ist halt irgendwann in diesem... Und jetzt will ich mal die Welt verändern. Jetzt habe ich erst die Welt verstanden. Bis zu dem Punkt war er sehr interessant. Und an dem Punkt war gesagt, jetzt will ich mal die Welt verändern. Also wie ich halt irgendwie...
Also das... Wie politisiere ich meine Wissenschaft? Genau, genau. Und das war auch der Punkt, wo ich sagen würde, dass er nun quasi dem freien Willen dann entgegen wirkt, wo er ein schnelles Denken, ein langsames Denken, was ich dazu sagen muss, das einzige Buch ist, was ich von ihm gelesen habe, wo er sehr deutlich in ganz vielen Facetten ausführt, wie wahnsinnig beeinflussbar......durch äußere Umstände die Menschen sind, dass im Prinzip man, wenn man das auf das Durchschnitt sieht, so was wie freien Willen sich gar nicht anmaßen soll zu haben.
Also das hab ich da aus ehrlich gesagt nicht geschlossen.
Naja, der hat ja zum Beispiel solche Sachen gemacht, wie die bekannten Experimente zitiert, dass du nur wenn du ein bestimmtes Wort liest, anschließend dich anders verhältst, dass du, wenn du mit Greisenhaftigkeit konfrontiert bist und dann über den Flur laufen sollst, sondern wirklich auch anfängst, langsamer und ein bisschen greisenhafter zu sein. Also wo du denkst, der Subtext ist und in manchen Bereichen auch der tatsächlich Überbau des Textes ist schon, Leute sind extrem beeinflussbar und zwar im Durchschnitt so stark beeinflussbar, dass man diesen freien Willen allenfalls punktuell feststellen kann und nicht als normal und gegeben voraussetzen kann. Und das ist die ideologische Basis dafür, dass du sagst, im Durchschnitt kannst du eine Gesellschaft steuern. Im Durchschnitt kannst du sagen, bei den richtigen Anreizsystemen tun die genau das, was ich machen möchte.
Interessante darin ist, dass sie sich damit in einem lustigen Zirkelschluss rechtsrum quasi bei den Chinesen wieder angestellt haben, die ja auch...
Und den Kybernetikern.
Das ist ein großer Kreis. Nämlich dieses Abkehr von dem Individualismus und dem... Also gut, der Individualismus als Ideologie gibt, den gibt es natürlich immer noch in der Gesellschaft, weil er ist tief genug verankert. Aber was ist dann eigentlich unser Ziel? Ist unser Ziel das Glück des Einzelnen oder das Glück der größeren Zahl? Und Nanjing geht halt wieder genau den Versuch, die Synthese davon zu machen, nämlich zu sagen, wir versuchen das Glück der größtmöglichen Zahl darüber zu erreichen, dass wir dem Einzelnen das Gefühl geben.
Wie er sei.
Und das genau Kahnemann, das genau diese...
Also ich hab das eher anders hergeleitet. Ich hab gesagt, das ist die Ausweitung des Neoliberalismus, dass der Markt wird es richten auf das Individuum. Dass du sagst, dich kann ich nicht lenken, aber ich kann dir Anreize geben. Das ist genau, was die Markttheoretiker immer sagen, um die Firmen zu mehr Steuergerechtigkeit zu bringen.
Ich möchte da nicht widersprechen. Ich möchte bloß diesen witzigen Widerspruch aufdecken, von dem ich nicht weiß, was ich damit mache. Dass du vorher, und da hab ich dir zugestimmt gesagt, dass ist das sozialistische Menschenbild. Und jetzt sagst du, das ist das neoliberale Menschenbild.
Wir haben gerade die Synthese. Die Singularität ist da.
Aber es ist tatsächlich, ich hab jetzt bei dir vorher gesagt, ja stimmt, das ist sozialistische Menschenbild. Das ist quasi diese kybernetische Ansatz einer planvoll durchgesteuerten Gesellschaft. Und jetzt kommst du und sagst, das ist neoliberale Gesellschaft. Und da würde ich auch sagen, naja, stimmt, hat schon recht, das ist das Modell des Markts. Und jetzt merke ich, ich hab gerade zwei Leuten Recht gegeben, die genau das Gegenteil voneinander gesagt haben. Das ist ja auch lustig als Erfahrung.
Was wir halt ja gerade sehen, ist halt genau diese Synthese. Also dieser Versuch, dieses jedes Individuum muss für sich der Markt sein. Und wir sind alle Teil eines Kollektivs. Wir müssen uns so vernünftig verhalten, dass wir als Kollektiv das Richtige erzielen. Das ist genau die Synthese aus beidem.
Wir wollen zwar alle steuern, aber wir glauben nicht, dass wir dich mit Planwirtschaft gesteuert kriegen. Sondern wir geben dir Anreize, damit der Markt dich steuert. Die Urthese des Kapitalismus, dass du egoistisch an deinem eigenen Vorteil interessiert bist, die nutzen wir aus, um dich planwirtschaftlich zu steuern.
Genau. Das ist halt eigentlich das, was wir...
Okay, dann haben wir jetzt also den dritten, den lange geforderten dritten Weg zwischen Sozialismus und Kapitalismus. Den haben wir jetzt und der ist kacke. Wir wissen noch nicht, ob er sozialistisch kacke oder neoliberal kacke ist, aber es könnte sein, dass er beidgleisig kacke ist. Und was er vor allem, und das ist vielleicht jetzt auch so im Schlussakkord unserer kleinen Sendung spannend, was vor allem von beiden Seiten auf uns zustürzt, ist, dass der Versuch der Gesellschaftssteuerung findet einen Weg der Überwachung zur Kontrolle. Weil beide Ansätze von beiden Seiten gehen davon aus, dass du etwas steuern möchtest. Und da musst du nicht nur rausfinden, ob du das Erfolg hast, sondern auch deine Premissen und deine Voraussetzungen überhaupt erstmal kennen. Und in dem Moment, wo du Gesellschaft steuerst, musst du Gesellschaft überwachen. Und zwar, je mehr du steuern möchtest, umso tiefer.
Das ist halt reine Kybernetiktheorie. Du brauchst halt mehr Daten, wenn du mehr steuern willst.
Und da ist genau der Ansatz, wo es anfängt, spannend zu werden, wie viel von dieser Totalüberwachung, die wir gerade haben, ist zufällig durch Geheimdiensteskalation entstanden. Wie viel ist durch politische Absicht entstanden. Ist vielleicht dieser ganze Geheimdienstkram nur ein Nebenprodukt von einer viel größeren Überwachungsideologie. Das wäre noch mal eine spannende, übrigens eher eine philosophische Frage, weil ich glaube nicht, dass man die wissenschaftlich beantworten kann. Aber leben wir in einem System, also westlichen System, das zielgerichtet zusteuert auf eine Totalüberwachungsgesellschaft, egal von welcher Seite man kommt. Einfach, weil wir in einem System leben, was geregelt werden möchte.
Nein, weil es technisch geht.
Okay, aber das ist ja für mich zum Beispiel schon mal fast ein erfrischender Ansatz. Das ist übrigens der, mit dem ich immer versuche, zu erklären, dass die Politik im Moment auf dem absteigenden Ast ist, weil die krassesten Techno-Vertreter halt bei den Geheimdiensten sitzen, deren einzige Beschränkung ist, das tun, was technisch machbar ist. Und damit sind sie die Verfechter von etwas, was über viele Jahre bekämpft wurde. Aber für mich ist diese Frage, und das ist eine wichtige Frage, wie ich finde, ist das gegenwärtige System, was ich jetzt nicht als so großes westliches Zivilisationsmuster oder so betrachten würde, sondern eher so als das, was rausgekommen ist, als der Kommunismus zusammengebrochen ist. Diese Melange aus regelmäßigen Volksbefragungen, Wahlen, Demokratieanteilen und Kapitalismus, also dass da was gerade so existiert, was ja offenbar gar nicht so unerfolgreich ist, so als, naja, es ist ziemlich unerfolgreich.
Unter gewissen Randbedingungen war es für zehn Jahre ungefähr sehr unerfolglich.
Es fängt halt immer von den Messdimensionen ab.
Steuern wir da drauf, dadurch auf eine Überwachungsgesellschaft zu, weil wir zu viel verlangen vom Prinzip Politik.
Ich würde nicht sagen dadurch, denn wenn man sich historisch anguckt, haben die schon immer überwacht, was sie konnten. Das Echelon-System ist älter als diese Überlegung Big Data.
Aber das Echelon-System lässt sich... Das Echelon-System...
Das Echelon-System lässt sich gegen die Sorte Nürnungen gerichtet, insofern war es halt...
Und Echelon wurde ja zum Beispiel auch nicht weltweit gemacht, sondern Echelon wurde in Deutschland gemacht und speziell für West-Berlin auch übrigens designed, wo halt tatsächlich nachweisbar, also die Spion-Dichte so hoch war, dass man einen Grund hatte, so ein unfassbar teures, unfassbar flächendeckendes System zu machen. Die Eskalation, die nach Echelon gekommen ist, ist ja, dass du alle immer überall überwachst und nicht nur eine bestimmte Gruppe.
Das hat Echelon schon auch probiert.
Lass uns mal kurz bei dieser Frage dieser Kontrollideologie bleiben, weil dahinter steht ja die Ansicht, dass...
Ist das nicht inhärent in allen Regierungssystemen?
Moment, dahinter steht ja...
Dass sie gar nicht kontrollieren wollen?
Nein, dahinter steht aber in gewisser Weise die Ansicht, dass man die Dinge nicht sich selbst überlassen darf, sondern dass, wenn man dieses Volk einfach nur machen lässt und vor sich hin wuseln lässt, dass es da immer nur Probleme gibt, weil alle möglichen Schwierigkeiten auftreten. Solange man dafür sorgt, dass die Leute, die das große Geld haben, mehr Geld verdienen.
Da wäre ich spezifischer übrigens. Da würde ich sagen, es ist genau die alte Ideologie aus dem 18. und 19. Jahrhundert. Die Leute sind zu doof, um sie wählen zu lassen. Das ist immer noch so. Du sagst halt, wir lassen sie nur selten wählen und den Rest müsste man nudging machen, damit sie das Richtige tun.
Bei Cameron würde ich da sofort zustimmen. Das ist halt das elitistischste System. Das ist übrigens auch sehr spannend, wenn man sich da anguckt, wie in Großbritannien das entstanden ist und wie das über die Erziehung quasi von Anfang an, von den Kindergärnen her sogar schon gedacht ist und in den Schulen ziemlich radikal weiter getrieben wird. Also wie sie da Leute regelrecht brechen in den eliten Schulen. Da gibt es viele interessante Studien zu. Im übergeordneten Kontext übrigens lohnt sich da sehr, sehr stark das Buch Prolls, untertitelt Dämonisierung der Arbeiterklasse, erklärt viel von dem vorgehen der britischen Regierung, angefangen von Thatcher bis hin zu bestimmten Medienerscheinungen, dass man wirklich versucht hat, so eine Elite rauszukristallisieren, die die Macht hat und darunter halt die große Masse, die Prolls sind und die sich dafür schämen sollen, dass sie so ein Unterschicht sind. Also wirklich so eine Dämonisierungstendenzen, die wir heute finden, bis hin, steht in diesem Buch, ja ich paraphrasiere nur, bis hin zu der Vorführung der Dummheit der Proleten in Casting-Shows. Also wo du einfach sagst, was ist denn das für ein Abschaum, der sich da... Das ist tatsächlich ungebildete Leute, so lächerlich wie möglich zu machen. Wahnsinnig spannendes Buch, kann ich nur empfehlen. Wenn wir also nach Großbritannien schauen, dann gibt es da tatsächlich diesen Ansatz. Ich frage mich aber...
Na bei uns nicht?
Na ja, ja.
Also bei uns hat die SPD immer aus Eigentums gegengesteuert und das Wahlalter runtergesetzt.
Wir haben halt nie diesen Saturismus in diesem Umfang gehabt, wo halt einfach quasi die gesamte Arbeit überwürgen komplett entkernt wurde. Das war bei uns ein schleichenderer Prozess und der hat auch dazu geführt, dass eben dadurch, dass wir halt eben nicht diese komplette Deinstabilisierung haben, es halt hier immer noch einfach Leute gibt, die auf stolz auf ihre Hände Arbeit sind und da wir auch kein großes Problem mit haben.
Ja und vor allem gab es nicht eine Dämonisierung der Arbeiterklasse, sondern fast im Gegend, weil es gab so eine Art Zusammenrücken. Natürlich hat sich die SPD in Richtung rechts und konservativ entwickelt, aber man kann einfach nicht leugnen, dass die CDU linker geworden ist. Das ist einfach faktisch messbar so. Es gibt so einen Zusammenrücken und dieses Zusammenrücken in Großbritannien so nicht stattgefunden.
Das ist komplett aus einer Devidierung. Aber lassen wir uns noch mal ganz kurz zum Abschluss bei diesem Punkt bleiben mit diesem Nudging und der gesellschaftlichen Kontrolle, weil letzten Endes ist ja die Frage, welchem Ziel dient es? Also was ist tatsächlich das Grundbedürfnis, was dadurch erfüllt wird? Und ich denke, zum einen ist es wiederum Stabilität, das Aufrechterhalten von dem Status Corona, also verhindern, dass sich halt irgendwie zu viel ändert. Und zum anderen denke ich aber auch, dass es halt durchaus ein sehr bewusster Weg ist, zu verhindern, dass sich das ökonomische System ändert. Also dass halt die Menschen, die halt irgendwie gerade auf den ein, zwei Prozent Bevölkerung, die halt irgendwie die größten Teile des Vermögens haben, dass sich deren Status ändert. Also dass sie halt irgendwie fürchten müssen, dass die Leute halt irgendwie keine Lust mehr haben.
Na doch, ändern tut er sich, aber in die falsche Richtung.
Also die wollen halt nicht, dass sich die Dinge ändern. Die wollen halt nicht, dass sich was daran ändert, dass die Leute gezwungen werden per Nudging, wirklich für 8,50 Euro bei all die an der Kasse zu stehen.
Das Spannende ist, es gibt da eine Debatte, die daran angrenzt, weil du ja sagst, Stabilität als Ohr ist das Ziel. Es gibt diesen schönen Begriff, auf den ich mich häufig zurückziehe, Verfassungspatriotismus, so geprägt von Sternberger und Habermas. Zu einem Zeitpunkt, als man in Westdeutschland überlegt hat, wie gehe ich eigentlich jetzt mit diesem Staat um? Ich kann einfach nicht stolz sein auf das, was da historisch gewachsen ist, aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen. Aber ich muss ja irgendwie mich dazu verhalten. Und da ist eben der Verfassungspatriotismus von Sternberger so nach vorne getragen worden. Und eines der zentralen Punkte, auf den dieser Verfassungspatriotismus aufbaut, ist, dass das Ziel jeder Politik ist und sein muss, Frieden. Und wenn man so lange vom Krieg weg ist, dass Frieden einfach nicht mehr diesen Grip hat, weil das ist ja klar, dass Frieden, also ein bisschen Frieden und so und es ist niemand mehr am Leben, der einen Krieg erlebt hat, so richtig jedenfalls hier vor Ort, dann gerinnt halt dieser Ziel, dass jeder Politik ist Frieden, gerinnt halt zu dieser Abstraktion von Frieden, dass es nicht mehr Abwesenheit von Krieg ist, wo es total nachvollziehbar ist. Bevor ein Krieg kommt, kann man eine ganze Menge mehr machen, als wir uns vielleicht im Moment so öffentlich eingestehen wollen. Also wenn da tatsächlich ein Krieg droht, dann denke ich, okay, da kann man vielleicht mal ein bisschen mit einer rauen Hand dabei gehen. Das ist eine Haltung, die man haben kann. Aber in dem Moment, wo Frieden halt gerinnt zur Stabilität und man immer noch sagt, das ist das einzige und oberste Ziel und wir haben keinerlei andere Ziele, was übrigens lustigerweise mit diesem merkischen Austeritätsgeföße ganz gut zusammenpassen würde, in dem Moment fängt es halt an schwierig zu werden. Und dann sind wir wieder bei so einem Zirkus Schluss.
Na ja, gut, also da stimme ich nicht ganz überein, weil tatsächlich hat diese Friedensgeschichte durchaus auch ganz konkrete Auswirkungen. Also zum Beispiel halt die Frage, wenn wir mit tierische Gewalt internationalen oder nicht, und sind wir irgendwie willens halt Dinge zu tun, die uns weiter in langfristige moralische Probleme stürzen, um kurzfristige moralische Probleme zu lösen. Also sprich, schicken wir die Bundeswehr in den Nordirak.
So ein Moment ausgerüstet, das macht es ja nicht den allergrößten Unterschied, ob wir es tun oder nicht.
Ich habe ja nicht umsonst getwittert, der große Vorteil einer strategisch nicht kriegsfähigen Bundeswehr ist, dass sie weniger Scheiß machen können weltweit. Aber das löst ja das politische Problem nur bedingt. Also was jetzt passieren wird, ist natürlich klar. Wir werden jetzt halt eine große Aufrüstungswelle bei der Bundeswehr leben und in zehn Jahren sind wir halt in der Lage, weltweit irgendwie der Scheiß zu machen.
Ich bin ziemlich sicher, dass es nicht so schnell geht. Aber die Richtung stimmt ja.
Wenn man erst McKinsey dran, sagen wir mal 20 Jahre.
Stimmt, wir haben McKinsey im Spiel. McKinsey könnte tatsächlich, also McKinsey als friedensschaffende Institution hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, was Fünfjahre mal sagen würde. Anyway, die Frage ist halt irgendwie, natürlich sind das eigentlich nicht eher Grundüberzeugungen. Also ist halt tatsächlich irgendwie die Frage, welche Mittel verwenden wir, sollten wir die nicht prinzipieller betrachten? Das war für mich so das Fazit aus diesem Jüdislawien-Ding halt, dass die Diskussionen, die wir da geführt haben, am Ende eigentlich nicht die richtigen waren, weil wir immer nur diskutiert haben, nicht einmischen oder einmischen mit militärischen Mitteln. Aber wir halt nicht darüber geredet haben, was geht denn eigentlich sonst noch?
Ja, gibt es nicht Situationen, frage ich erst mal ketzerisch, als erklärter Nicht-Pazifist. Gibt es nicht Situationen, wo es nur diese beiden Möglichkeiten gibt? Eingreifen militärisch oder nicht eingreifen?
Könne ich keine.
Also ich kann ja mal eine.
Nenn mal eine.
Das extrem häufig strapazierte Peacement-Beispiel aus den 30er Jahren des letzten Jahrhunderts.
Aber wenn man irgendwie weiß, was da passiert ist, kommt man auch wieder darauf, dass es auch durchaus echt andere Mittel gegeben hätte.
Also das sagt man so, aber dann auch wieder kann man sehr stark darüber diskutieren, ob das wirklich so ist.
Ein andermal.
Ich glaube, das ist eine andere Diskussion. Aber ich glaube auch, dass da man sehr schnell auf unfassbar dünnem Eis wandelt, wenn man halt dieses militärische Ding betrachtet. Weil man kann halt, und das ist der Kern, und das ist in Deutschland immer der Urgrund, nämlich Nationalsozialismus, Dritte Reich. Hinter allem steht das praktisch, was man moralisch diskutiert. Und da muss man halt fragen, geht man jetzt linksrum aus der Geschichte gelernt oder rechtsrum? Sagt man, von Deutschland darf nie wieder irgendwas ausgehen, was in die Richtung gehen könnte von einem militärischen Angriffskrieg? Das wäre ein mögliches historisches Learning. Oder sagt man, wenn irgendwo anders so was ähnliches wie dieser Faschismus anfängt zu existieren, hat man dann geradezu die Pflicht einzugreifen, weil man sonst das, was in Deutschland zu lange gewähren gelassen worden ist, da gewähren lässt. Also das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Lernansätze aus der Geschichte. Aber ich glaube, das führt tatsächlich insgesamt zu weit.
Wir brauchen mehr Bomben für den Frieden.
Das ist auch sehr profitabel und vor allen Dingen schafft das Arbeitsplätze.
Richtig.
Na gut, dann machen wir mal Schluss. Vielen Dank.
Ja, danke.
Ja, wir entschuldigen uns diesmal nicht dafür, dass wir so lange gebraucht haben, aber wir haben vergleichsweise kurz gebraucht für die nächste Sendung. Wir hoffen, dass wir es das nächste Mal auch wieder relativ zügig schaffen. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wenn ihr Lust habt, könnt ihr noch auf den Flatter-Button drücken und dann bis zum nächsten Mal.